OKAY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I
I'M GOING TO MAKE SEVERAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
THE PROCESSES WE HAVE DEVELOPED
TO CONTINUE OUR CENTRAL WORK
DURING THE PANDEMIC. FOR THOSE
OF YOU FAMILIAR WITH THIS
PROCESS WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE WHILE I GO THROUGH IT
ONE MORE TIME FOR THOSE WHO
MIGHT BE TUNING IN FOR THE FIRST
TIME. SO I'M GOING TO COVER THE
TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS FOR
TODAY IN RESPONSE TO THE CODE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND WE CAN MAKE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
. IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS BOB
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WITH ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT. THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY REMOTELY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT WE HAVE A PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE. IT'S POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. RIGHT
NOW ITIS BEING DISPLAYED THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN ONE SEVEN SIX
EIGHT TWO SIX. WE WILL REPEAT
THIS A COUPLE OF TIMES DURING
THE COMMITTEE SO THAT- PEOPLE
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT INFORMATION
. WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY WILL
OPEN YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ANY FEEDBACK YOU MUST ACTUALLY
MUTE THE DEVICE THAT YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND THAT WILL ALLOW US
TO DO SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN INDIA INDIVIDUALS
WHO WILL- WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES. FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO OUR NEW ONLINE TOOL
SO AGAIN LET'S JUST BE PATIENT
SO EVERYONE CAN BE HEARD. ON
BEHALF OF OUR COURT REPORTER I'M
GOING TO ASK ALL SPEAKERS MY
COLLEAGUES AND WITNESSES ALIKE
TO SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY. IF
I HAVE TO INTERRUPT YOU WE WILL
ONLY BE FOR. PROBABLY THAT
REASON SO THAT WE'RE ABLE TO GET
YOUR TESTIMONY. BEFORE WE BEGIN
TODAY'S AGENDA I WANT TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. A REMINDER
TO MY COLLEAGUES YOU'LL NEED TO
TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE FOR THE
ROLL CALL AND EVERY TIME THAT WE
VOTE. THE MAN SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HERE HERE
KAMLAGER NO LONGER HERE LAYERED-
LAYERED HERE BATES YEAH AS HERE
ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE THANK
YOU MADAM SECRETARY- I WILL JUST
FOR PUBLIC BENEFITS- IT
KNOWLEDGE THAT YET AGAIN WE END
UP DOING DOUBLE DUTY TODAY THAT
WILL BE SENATOR COM LOGGER WHO
HAS TO LEAVE TO CHAIR A BUDGET
SUB FOR MEETING BUT SHE WILL BE
BACK AND FORTH- AS WE NEED HER
TO BE- BUT I DON'T WANT THE
PUBLIC TO THINK YOU ARE. JUST
GIVEN OUT HERE YOU'RE GOING TO
BE- HAD NEVER TO CHAIR A VERY
IMPORTANT BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
I'M SO WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO
IF POSSIBLE WITH MY COLLEAGUES
IS TAKE UP ARMS. FIRST ON
TODAY'S AGENDA GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR. I WANT I WILL ASK OUR-
ARE WE ABLE TO TAKE THEM ALL. TO
THE THROUGH I OR WOULD WE
SEPARATE OUT SOME AND I'M HAPPY
TO. THAT IS WONDERFUL THANK YOU
ARE THAT WOULD BE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR AND THAT WOULD BE TO BE
THROUGH G. R. FOR APPOINTMENTS
TO THE ACUPUNCTURE BOARD. N. H.
N. I. R. TWO APPOINTMENTS TO THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS. I SENATOR
GROWTH HAS MADE THAT MOTION.
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ROVE I WROTE I
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER I LAYERED
HI THERE I BATES RIGHT IT'S AYE
ATKINS HI I CAN SIDE RIGHT NOW
FIVE TWO ZERO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COLLEAGUES IN ON ITEM
NUMBER THREE REFERENCE OF BILLS
TO COMMITTEE I'M GOING TO DO. A
SEPARATION I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
SEPARATE OUT TWO PIECES OF
LEGISLATION FROM THE REFERENCE
OF BILLS THE LIST. I WILL
SEPARATE OUT S. B. EIGHT SIX SIX
WIENER. N. S. B. EIGHT SEVEN ONE
HEY N. I WILL SEPARATE THOSE OUT
AND ASK FOR A MOTION ON THE
REMAINDER OF THE REFERENCE OF
BILLS TO COMMITTEES. I WOULD
MOVE THE REMAINING BILLS THANK
YOU ARE SENATOR LAYERED- SO
MADAM SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL
ON THEIR- ROAF. I WROTE I
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER I LAYERED
HI THERE I BATES RIGHT IF I
ATKINS HI ATKINS AYE. THANK YOU
MY CAR FOR THAT NOW WE HAVE TO
BILLS WILL BE VOTED ON
SEPARATELY R. FOR ROMEO REFERRAL
OF BILLS TO COMMITTEES AND THAT
WOULD BE SB EIGHT SIX SIX WIENER
AND SB EIGHT SEVEN ONE PAN A
MOTION SO MOVE. THANK YOU
SENATOR COM LONGER MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL. ROVE
NOPE ROOF NO KAMLAGER HI
MARGARET I LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES NO IT'S- AT. HIGH ATKINS I
READ TWO THREE TO TWO. OF THOSE
HAVE BEEN REFERRED- COLLEAGUE
THANK YOU HAVE ONE MORE ITEM
IT'S A RULE REQUEST. FROM
SENATOR PORTANTINO WITH THIS-ITEM FOR TO SUSPEND US SENATE
RULE TO TWO POINT FIVE BILL
INTRODUCTION LIMITATION. TO
INTRODUCE FOR ADDITIONAL BILLS
DUE TO THE ANNUAL STATE CLAIMS
BILLS WHICH THE TERRIBLE
PROCREATION IS. HAS TO KERRY.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROW- MA'AM
SECRETARY WE THE ROLL. ROVE I
GROVE I KAMLAGER I WATER I
THERE'D. THERE'D AYE BATES AYE
IT'S AYE ATKINS AYE AT FIVE ZERO
FIVE JUST. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND TO NOW TO GO
OF RICK TO APPEAR. AND ITEM ONE
A. IS APPOINT OF NADDA. ALLUDE I
ALLUVIAL AYE I KNEW I WOULD MESS
THAT UP OUR PLEASE FORGIVE ME-
AS SECRETARY OF THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
AND- I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AS WE ARE GOT
UNDERWAY AND HANDLED SOME OF
THE- ITEMS FOR CONSENT- IF YOU
SECRETARY WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE YOURSELF- IT KNOWLEDGE
ANYONE THAT'S WITH YOU THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO THANK AND THEN.
MAKE ANY OPENING COMMENTS YOU
ARE WELCOME TO DO THAT AND AFTER
YOU'RE ABLE TO MAKE YOUR
INTRODUCTION TECHNOLOGY METHOD
OPENING COMMENTS WE WILL GO
RIGHT TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS THEMSELVES SO WITH
THAT LET ME SAY WELCOME. THANK
YOU MADAM PROTON AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND BOTTOM PRO TEM
YOU PRONOUNCE MY NAME PERFECTLY
SO I THINK YOU FOR THAT AS WELL.
I AM HONORED AND GRATEFUL TO BE
HERE TODAY AND SERVICE OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS AND AS THE STATE'S
FIRST LATINO SECRETARY OF THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGECY. I THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. I OFTEN TELL MY
COLLEAGUES I HAVE SHARED WITH
MANY OF YOU AND YOUR STAFF THAT
BEING HERE IS A LIFETIME
ACHIEVEMENT. FOR A LIFELONG
PUBLIC SERVANTS SUCH AS MYSELF
WHO HAS BEEN COMMITTED TO
ASSURING GOVERNMENT IS RELEVANT
IMPACTFUL AND CONTINUOUSLY
IMPROVING. I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
A FEW PEOPLE THAT ARE HERE
SUPPORTING ME TODAY. FIRST THE
TWO PEOPLE WHO HAVE STEADFASTLY
SUPPORTED ME MY ENTIRE LIFE. MY
PARENTS FATAL AND MONEY ANY
LARA. WHO IS IMMIGRANTS HAVE
SACRIFICED MUCH FOR THE MY
BROTHER DANIEL AND I COULD
THRIVE AND IN RETURN TO
CONTRIBUTE MUCH. THEY TAUGHT ME
THE VALUE OF SERVING OTHERS BY
DOING IT THEMSELVES. I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE ALSO MY HUSBAND RYAN
WHO IS HERE WITH ME TODAY
ANOTHER LIFELONG PUBLIC
SERVANTS. WHO REMINDS ME EVERY
DAY THAT OUR WORK HAS A
MEANINGFUL IMPACT EVEN WHEN THE
CHALLENGES SEEM OVERWHELMING.
AND TO MY TWO BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN
ISABELLA AGE EIGHT AND BRUNO H.
FIVE. YOUR MOM DIED OF SERVE
BECAUSE OF YOU YOU INSPIRE US TO
WORK FOR A FUTURE THAT IS
GREATER AND MORE RESILIENT THAN
THE GENERATIONS PRIOR THEY ARE
EXAMPLES SHOW YOU THAT IDEALS
AND DREAMS ABOUT MAKING THE
WORLD A BETTER PLACE HAVE A
PLACE IN THE WORLD. AND LASTLY I
OF COURSE WANT TO THANK GOVERNOR
NEW SONG FOR THE TRUST HE HAS
PLACED IN ME TO LEAD THIS
IMPORTANT AGENCY DURING THIS
TIME OF ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
TRANSITION. AND WITH THAT I AM
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY AND ALL
QUESTIONS. OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WILL MAKE TWO CORRECTIONS ONE WE
ONLY HAVE ONE- HEARING ROOM
TODAY PLEASE FORGIVE ME FOR
SAYING TO. I ALSO WANT TO GIVE-
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT CREDIT TO
SENATOR GROVE WHO HAS TO GO
SERVE ON SUB FIVE SO. I JUST
LIKE TO MAKE SURE THE PUBLIC
KNOWS THAT WHEN COLLEAGUES LEAVE
LEAVE THEY ARE ACTUALLY LEAVING
TO GO DO OTHER- WORK RELATED
BUSINESS BUT I THEY WILL BE
BACK. AND WITH THAT I WOULD JUST
SAY TO YOU I I'M SURE YOUR
LOVELY CHILDREN ARE IN SCHOOL
BUT WE ALWAYS LOVE TO SEE THE
FACES OF LOVED ONES IN
PARTICULAR. KIDS SO WE'RE SORRY
WE MISSED THE MAYBE YOU WILL GET
A- MESSAGE YES I DEFINITELY WILL
THINK YOU CENTER OKAY- CENTER
LAYERED HOW ABOUT I START WITH
YOU AND THEN I'LL GO TO MADAM
VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU- MADAM
CHAIR. THANK FOR- OPPORTUNITY-
TO MEET OUR I APPRECIATED IT I
THOUGHT I'D ASK YOU A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT CAME OUT OF
OUR CONVERSATION. AND ONE OF
THEM WAS. I ASKED YOU- SINCE YOU
HAD HAD MOST OF YOUR CAREER OUT
OF STATE AND WE'RE COMING IN TO
CALIFORNIA. OR WHAT IT WAS LIKE
AND HOW YOU EXPECTED TO
COMPENSATE FOR THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE LEARNING CALIFORNIA
PROCESSES AND CALIFORNIA
RELATIONSHIPS- IN YOUR JOB.
THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED- AND
IT WAS WONDERFUL MEETING WITH
YOU AS WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT
OPPORTUNITY- YESTERDAY. THAT IS
SO WE DISCUSSED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THIS YOU KNOW COMING UP
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
SERVING AS A PUBLIC SERVANT NOW
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS. THE
EXPERIENCES OF WORKING IN
GOVERNMENT ARE VERY SIMILAR SO
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA IN ADMINISTERING
THE A LARGE AGENCY ARE NOT ALL
THAT DIFFERENT FROM
ADMINISTERING A LARGE FEDERAL
AGENCY. AND SO IN THAT SENSE I
FEEL LIKE I CAME VERY PREPARED
AND READY AND HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
JUMP IN VERY QUICKLY TO THE
ISSUES AND TO PRIORITIZE SEEN
WHERE WE NEED TO FOCUS OUR
EFFORTS. IN TERMS OF THE
RELATIONSHIP THE AREAS WHERE I
COME UP WITH A BIT OF A
DISADVANTAGE. I YOU KNOW I YOU
NATURALLY OF A RELATIONSHIP
BUILDER I FEEL THAT IT IS MY JOB
TO. BREAK DOWN SILOS ASSURE THAT
I'M WORKING CLOSELY WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THE OTHER
SECRETARIES. TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE SENATE AND WITH THE
ASSEMBLY AND WITH ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN CALIFORNIA BOTH
ON THE EMPLOYER SIDE AND THAT
THE WORKER SIDE. AND SO I HAVE
BEEN FOCUSING QUITE A BIT OF MY
TIME ON BUILDING THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS AND GETTING OUT
THERE ARE TO OUR LOCAL AREAS AND
GETTING TO KNOW WHAT THEIR
INDIVIDUAL SPECIFIC CHALLENGES
ARE AS WE COME OUT OF COLLUDED.
AND ENTER. THIS NEW PHASE OF
RECOVERY. GRAY THANK YOU I
PREFER THAT THE OTHER A I
THOUGHT ARE ASK YOU. A WE TALK.
YESTERDAY ABOUT. I COUNT ABILITY
MEASUREMENT SO THAT YOU HAVE A
WAY OF ASSESSING. THE WORK YOU
DO AND HOW SUCCESSFUL IT IS AND
IF YOU COULD TALK ABOUT THAT SO
WE WOULD UNDERSTAND HOW WOULD
YOU EXPECT TO HOLD
ACCOUNTABILITY IN YOUR POSITION
. ABSOLUTELY AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT VERY IMPORTANT QUESTION AND
IT IS ONE THAT CAME UP. IN MANY
OF MY CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
REST OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ONE OF MY KEY AREAS OF FOCUS
DURING MY PUBLIC SERVICE CAREER
HAS BEEN THE YOU KNOW MAKING
SURE THAT THE BUSINESS OF
GOVERNMENT. IS A TOP PRIORITY
FOR POLICYMAKERS SO NOT ONLY
FOCUSING ON THE POLICIES THAT
MAKE AN IMPACT ON PEOPLE'S LIVES
BUT ALSO ON HOW WELL GOVERNMENT
OPERATES HOW IS CONTINUES WE
IMPROVING ANY INNOVATIVE. TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE
THAT IT SERVES. AND SO MY GOAL
HERE- THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY IS TO BRING
MY EXPERIENCES. FROM MY FEDERAL
SERVICE YEARS AND TO IMPLEMENT
MORE A MORE ROBUST STRUCTURE
AROUND PERFORMANCE MANAGEMENT
AND EVIDENCE BUILDING. SO THAT
WE MAY BE DEMONSTRATING TO THE
PUBLIC FOR THE VALUE THAT WE
OFFER. AND THAT WE ARE
CONTINUOUSLY PRIORITISING AND
MEASURING OURSELVES AGAINST
THOSE PRIORITIES PRIORITIES.
GREAT OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME RESPONSE TO
THE QUESTION. THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED MAN VICE CHAIR. THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU SECRETARY WE
DID HAVE A VERY NICE VISIT
YESTERDAY I WAS ABLE TO SQUEEZE
YOU IN ACTUALLY PASS YOUR DINNER
TIME AND I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT
PROBABLY DIDN'T KNOW YOU HAD
KIDS OUT THERE THAT MIGHT BE
WAITING FOR THAT SO. THAT TIME
LET ME SAY JUST OFF THE TOP-
THERE'S ALWAYS THE CONCERN ABOUT
THE PRIVATE ACTION- HOW THE
ISSUE KNOWING YOU YOU DID NOT
EXPERIENCE THAT INTO YOU CAME TO
CALIFORNIA. I WAS VERY PLEASED
TO HEAR THAT YOU BE OPEN TO
DISCUSSION ABOUT SOME OF THE
REFORMS THAT. ARE COULD BE AND
SHOULD BE NECESSARY FOR
PROTECTING AND IN PARTICULAR I
THINK ALL THE FOCUS WAS ON. OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES SO I REALLY
APPRECIATED THAT YOU HAVE. AN
OPEN MIND AND GO WE'LL TAKE A
DEEPER DIVE INTO THAT IF
INFORMATION COMES FORWARD AND
YOU WANT TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATORS I APPRECIATED THAT.
I JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS THAT BUILD ON OUR-
VERY ODD. INFORMATIVE DISCUSSION
YESTERDAY AND I WONDER IF THE
CLAIMS PROCESSING- WE DID RUN
INTO ISSUES WITHOUT.
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM
THERE WERE MANY THINGS AWAY IN
THE COMPUTER SYSTEM. SO THE
QUESTION IS- HELLO- HOW ARE WE
GOING TO BE SURE THAT WAS STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE SB I IF
IT'S USING THE SAME COMPUTER
PROCESSOR. THAT WE WON'T START
TO RUN INTO SOME SIGNIFICANT.
FRAUD ISSUES THERE AND I KNOW A
FEWHAVE MEMBERS NOT NOT TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE'VE SEEN WITH YOUR
A. B. THAT COULD YOU SHARE A
LIBERATE CONVEYED YOU DID
RESPOND TO THAT BUT- ABURRIDA
LITTLE. ON THE PUBLIC RECORD I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS. ALSO SENATOR AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION
FRAUD IS NO FRAUD OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SYSTEM
HERE IN OUR STATE AND ACROSS.
ALL OF OUR STATE. HAS BEEN TOP
OF MIND FOR MANY. AND AS WE KNOW
IDENTITY FRAUD IT IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST VULNERABILITIES THAT WE
HAVE AS A SOCIETY TODAY
UNFORTUNATELY. AND THE PANDEMIC
ON COVERED A LOT OF THIS HERE IN
OUR STATE WITH OUR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE SYSTEM. AND THE
PROCESSING. THERE ARE FOUR KEY
ACTIONS THAT WE TALK DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND THAT WE ARE
CONTINUING TO REVISE AND REVIEW
CURRENTLY- TO COMBAT FRAUD. THE
FIRST ONE WAS EARLY ON IN THE
PANDEMIC WE CONTRACTED WITH
THOMSON REUTERS TO PROVIDE. US
SOME DATA ANALYSIS AND FILTERS
THAT WE COULD USE TO IDENTIFY
POTENTIALLY FRAUDULENT CLAIMS.
THAT PROCESS EVOLVED OVER TIME
NOT SO THOSE FILTERS HAVE
EVOLVED AND THEY ARE STILL IN
PLACE AND THEY'RE VERY HELPFUL
IN IDENTIFYING FRAUD THAT ISN'T
ALWAYS IDENTITY FRAUD COULD BE
OUT OF STATE FRAUD THERE COULD
BE DIFFERENT TYPES OF FRAUD THAT
THESE FILTERS HELP US IDENTIFY.
THE SECOND IS A TOOL IT'S A
TECHNOLOGY TOOL THAT MANY
AGENCIES HAVE STARTED TO USE
BOTH IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND WITHIN CALIFORNIA AND THAT
IS IT NEED. SO I DO NEED IS
FOCUSED ON THE FRONT END TO OUR
VERIFY IDENTITIES OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE. SUBMITTING CLAIMS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND SO
THAT HAS SIGNIFICANTLY. CONTROL
LEVELS OF FRAUD OF. THE THIRD.
LARGE PIECE IS THAT THE- EDT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ACTUALLY PUT
TOGETHER A FRAUD A UNITS SO THIS
IS A GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
WILL CONTINUOUSLY BE ASSESSING.
THE ANALYTICS THE DATA AROUND
OUR CLAIMS TRYING TO STAY AHEAD
AND NOT BE REACTIVE TO NEW
ATTACKS OF FRAUD. AND FOURTH BOB
VERY IMPORTANT PIECE THAT WE
HAVE CONTRACTED WITH FORMER U.
S. ATTORNEY MCGREGOR SCOTT AND
HIS ROLE HAS BEEN TO HELP US
MOVE FRAUDULENT- OF. EVIDENCE
THAT WE HAD INTO THE HANDS OF
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO THAT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS CAN BE PROSECUTED.
SO THAT IS ON THE BACK AND THE
ACTUAL PROSECUTION OF THE
CRIMINAL FRAUD THAT HAS BEEN
OCCURRING DOMESTICALLY AS WELL
AS INTERNATIONALLY. AND SO IN
TERMS OF D. II WE TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THIS. WE ARE THESE OF
SORTS OF FEATURES ARE NOT IN
PLACE OUR SYSTEMS ARE VULNERABLE
TO FRAUD AND SO WE HAVE A LOOK
AT OUR BENEFITS ADMINISTRATION.
SYSTEMS BUT DISABILITY INSURANCE
IS ONE OF THEM AND WE ARE.
IMPLEMENTING ALL OF THESE PIECES
INTO THE DISABILITY INSURANCE
PROGRAM WHICH IS ALSO VERY
VULNERABLE TO THESE SORTS OF
IDENTITY THEFT FRAUD- I WOULD OF
COURSE YOU KNOW WANT TO STATE
THAT WE ARE CONSTANTLY REVIEWING
AND ASSESSING WHAT FRAUD LOOKS
LIKE. AND TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
NEED TO PUT NEW TOOLS IN PLACE
OR YOU KNOW WE THINK OUR
STRATEGIES WE ARE DOING SO WE'RE
TRYING TO DO THAT IN REAL TIME
SO THAT WE'RE NOT BEHIND THE
CURVE. GREAT ANSWER AND
APPRECIATE THAT YOU ARE THINKING
OF THE PRESIDENT AND THEN.
TAKING THOSE LESSONS LEARNED I
GUESS INTO THE FUTURE. THERE HAS
BEEN AN ISSUE REYES THAT THE
VISUAL ARTS. RECOGNITION CONDIT-
I THINK GOING FORWARD. CREATE
SOME PRIVACY ISSUES I'M NOT SURE
IF YOU'RE VERY OUT WITH. HAVING
SOME SORT OF CHALLENGE ON THAT
BUT IT JUST IT'S VERY VERY
RECENT THAT HAS EMERGED BECAUSE
IT'S BEING USED MORE. SO ANY
THOUGHT FOUND OUT WHY NO WE
DIDN'T DISCUSS THAT THAT TIME
HAVE YOU HAD A JOB FROM- I GIVEN
THE ISSUES RAISED ON OUT ALREADY. YES I'VE SENATOR AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH. OUR PARTNERS OTHER
STATES AND LOOKING AT WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS DOING WHEN
IT COMES TO ID ME AND THE FACIAL
RECOGNITION TOOL. THAT ALLOWS AN
INDIVIDUAL TO TAKE A SELFIE-
AND- AND SO THAT THE TECHNOLOGY
CAN QUICKLY CROSS REFERENCE THAT
ADDITIONAL IDENTIFICATION WITH
OTHER FORMS OF IDENTIFICATION.
ARE WE ARE ASSESSING CURRENTLY
OUT WHETHER WE WANT TO MOVE IN
THE DIRECTION THAT THE IRS HAS
MOVED WHICH IS ACTUALLY
PROVIDING OPTIONALITY FOR USERS
OF ID ME. WHERE THEY CAN CHOOSE
TO CONTINUE WITH FACIAL
RECOGNITION. OR THEY CAN CHOOSE
NOT TO OPT INTO THAT AND THERE
WILL BE AN ALTERNATIVE WAY OF
VERIFYING IDENTITY WHICH IS WITH
A LIVE INTERMEDIARY. THAT COMES
ON AND- VERIFIES THE IDENTITY OF
THE PERFECT PERSON WITHOUT A
SELFIE HAVING TO BE TAKEN.
INTEREST WE ARE EVALUATING
CURRENTLY ASSESSING THOSE
OPTIONS. AND IRIS IS USING THAT
INTERESTING. LAST QUESTION I
THINK WE DID DISCUSS THIS
BECAUSE IT'S VERY. CONCERNING TO
YOU AGAIN OUR TO OUR SMALLER
BUSINESSES THE UNIT. THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FUND OUT
TO HAND OUT YOU WITH HUGE WITH
THE GREAT RECESSION TOOK A
DECADE TO RETIRE. OUR COMING AT
IT AGAIN MAYBE YOU CAN SHARE
SOME OF OUR OUR CONVERSATION AND
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT BUT AGAIN.
BOB WHAT TO REITERATE THAT WE
BELIEVE THERE SHOULD BE MORE OF
THE CURRENT SURPLUS AND I THINK
THAT THAT WOULD HELP. AT LEAST
IN THE FOR A PARTICULAR PERIOD
OF REDUCE THAT BURDEN THAT THAT
WOULD BE IN PARTICULAR ON THE
SMALL BUSINESS AND THAT IS.
CLEARLY THE BASE AND I DISTRICTS
SO YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT AGAIN
FOR ALL YOU. KNOW PUBLIC.
DISCUSSION I'M CENTER YES THE
QUESTION OF- YOU I SAW IN SPEED.
COMES UP AGAIN AND- AND THERE'S
SORT OF TWO TO THREE I WOULD
LIKE TO ADDRESS- I. OF COURSE
YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR IS PUTTING
IN HIS BUDGET IS PROPOSING THREE
POINT ONE BILLION TO PAY DOWN
THE FEDERAL DEBT THAT WE HAVE.
FOR YOU I TRUST FUND AND I OF
COURSE FEEL LIKE THAT IS THE
RIGHT STEP- IN SHOWING. THE
SUPPORT TO OUR BUSINESSES IN
STARTING TO PAY THAT DOWN. OUT
WHAT THAT WILL DO IS IT'LL
SHORTEN THE AMOUNT OF TIME BUT
THE STATE OWES THIS DEBT TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THE OTHER
ISSUE THAT WE DISCUSSED IN OUR
CONVERSATION WHICH I REALLY
APPRECIATED IT WAS SORT OF THE
LONGER THE LONGER TERM VISION.
AND SORT OF FACING THE REALITY
THAT. WHEN THERE ARE ECONOMIC OF
CRISES YOU KNOW SUCH AS THE
GREAT RECESSION AND WORE THE
PANDEMIC WHICH WAS TREMENDOUS IN
TERMS OF THE IMPACT ON
EMPLOYMENT. WE ALWAYS END UP IN
THE CYCLE OF INSOLVENCY WITH OUR
FUND AND HAVING TO BORROW MONEY
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT MY AGENCY
CAN BE HELPFUL TO YOU AND OTHERS
ON THE COMMITTEE OR OTHER
SENATORS OR SIMPLY MEMBERS IN
ANALYZING WHAT THE OPTIONS ARE-
WHEN LOOKING AT YOU KNOW OUR
TRUST FUND. WE ARE HERE OUR
DOORS ARE OPEN AND WE ARE
WILLING TO PROVIDE AS MUCH
INFORMATION AS POSSIBLE ON WHAT
THOSE OPTIONS COULD LOOK LIKE
AND WHAT MODELS OTHER STATES
HAVE ADOPTED. SO THAT THEY ARE
NOT CONTINUOUSLY IN THE CYCLES
EVERY TIME THERE IS A RECESSION.
WELL THANK YOU FOR THOSE
RESPONSES TO MY QUESTIONS ON.
YOU HAVE A BIG JOB AHEAD OF YOU
IT LOOKS LIKE YOUR ARE YOUR
WEALTH- AWARE OF THAT AND
CERTAINLY HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
SKILL SET TO BRING TO THE JOBS
WHO WISH YOU WELL AND YOU WILL
HAVE MY SUPPORT. WELL NOW WITH
THE VOTE IS TAKEN OUT THANK YOU
AGAIN. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR SENATOR COBBLER. THANK YOU
. FOR THAT MADAM ROPED HIM I-
WANNA THANK YOU FOR SPENDING
SOME TIME WITH ME YESTERDAY-
THAT WAS INFORMATIVE AND YOU WHO
HAVE A BIG TASK AHEAD OF YOU- WE
DID TALK ABOUT THIS BUT I WANT
TO JUST- ASK IT AGAIN SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE A- A DISCUSSION ABOUT
IT ON THE RECORD- BUT I AM.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
KNOW THAT- THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIANS- WHO ARE IN THE
LABOR. WORKFORCE IN WHO ARE
TRYING TO GET INTO IT AND STAY
INTO IT AND HAVE IT BE SAFE AND
PROTECTIVE. I'D LIKE YOU TO
SHARE. YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW
COMMUNITIES WITH- HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT. AND I THINK I
MENTIONED TO YOU THAT MY
DISTRICT WAS- THE DISTRICT WITH
ONE OF THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF
OPEN CLAIMS DURING THE PANDEMIC
SO HOW ARE COMMUNITIES WITH
HIGH. NUMBERS OF UNEMPLOYMENT-
AND JOB TRAINING VOIDS BEING
SERVED. ESPECIALLY GIVEN THERE
MIGHT BE. HOLES IN THE SERVICES
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING TO THEM
AND SO YOU KNOW THE SPECIFIC
PART OF THAT IS AS AS I SHARED
WITH YOU YOU KNOW I HAVE A
BUILDING IN MY DISTRICT IN EDV
BUILDING THAT'S BEEN CLOSED FOR
ALMOST SEVEN YEARS AND THE
SERVICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
THROUGH THAT FACILITY HAVE BEEN
COLOCATED INTO OTHER- CITIES AND
AREAS OUTSIDE OF. LA AND IT
CAUSED A MAJOR DISRUPTION- FOR
FOLKS WHO ARE. WHO WANT TO SEE
THE STATE IN THEIR DISTRICT IN
THEIR COMMUNITY IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD- AVAILABLE TO THEM.
SO GRANTED MANY PLACES WERE
CLOSED DURING THE PANDEMIC BUT
IT'S NOT REALLY ABOUT THAT SO
JUST WANTED TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS
ON HOW IN SPACES- LIKE SOUTH LA
WHERE THERE IS A VOID OF
RESOURCES THAT PEOPLE CAN SEE.
HOW ARE YOU STILL WORKING TO
MAKE SURE THAT CONSTITUENTS
FEEL- THE SUPPORT OF THE STATE
ESPECIALLY WITH ISSUES THAT ARE
REALLY CRITICAL LIKE YOU KNOW
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS BEINGABLE
TO GET YOUR BENEFITS BEING ABLE
TO GET HELP. WITH JOB TRAINING
SKILLS LIKE CETERA. THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR YOUR QUESTION AND
ALSO FOR THE TIME THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO SPEND YESTERDAY SO I'LL
TAKE YOUR QUESTION AND INTO
PARTS BECAUSE- THERE THERE ARE
TWO PARTS TO IT. SO ON THE
CRENSHAW BUILDING. AS YOU KNOW
WHEN I WILL SPEAK THIS FOR THE
RECORD- EDT HAS BEEN IN AND
FIGHT A LEGAL BATTLE OVER THIS
PROPERTY FOR MANY YEARS- THIS
PROPERTY WAS A LEASE TO OWN. AND
WHEN IT WAS TIME TO ACTUALLY OWN
THE BUILDING OWNER AND HIS
FAMILY FOX ABOUT OWNERSHIP PIECE
OF THE CONTRACT AND SO THIS HAS
BEEN- IN THE COURTS FOR A WHILE
THE COURTS DECIDED. THAT THE
OWNERS NEEDED TO HAND OVER THE
DEED AND THAT THE YOU KNOW THE
TITLE OF THIS BUILDING TO EDT.
AND THEY HAVE ALSO DENIED- AN
APPEAL OF THAT. SO THE GOOD NEWS
IS THAT IT LOOKS LIKE THIS
THE NOTGREAT NEWS IS THAT WE
STILL KNOCK WE STILL HAVE NOT
RECEIVED- THE HANDOVER OF THE
DEED AND TITLE FOR THAT PROPERTY
AND THAT'S THE FINAL PIECE SO
ONCE THAT IS DONE. I LOOK
FORWARD YOU KNOW TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND WE- WILL ASSESS THE
CONDITION OF THAT BUILDING. SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE FIXES TO IT- MY
UNDERSTAND IS NOT IN GREAT SHAPE
RIGHT NOW- AND THEN OF COURSE WE
WOULD WANT TO WORK WITH YOU ON.
PLANNING AND FOX ABOUT RE
OCCUPYING THAT BUILDING AND WHAT
THAT MIGHT LOOK LIKE AND HOW.
THAT WOULD BEST SERVE THAT
COMMUITY. ON THE BROADER. ABOUT
AREA WITH HIGH AND A LACK OF
SERVICES. THIS IS THE WORST
POSSIBLE SITUATION TO HAVE AN
AREA THAT IS ECONOMICALLY
DEPRESSED WITH INDIVIDUALS WHO
NEED JOBS AND WERE SERVICES ARE
LACKING SO THAT CONFLUENCE OF
FACTORS IS. VERY UPSETTING TO ME
AS LABOR SECRETARY AND SO ONE OF
MY PRIORITIES IS TO WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH ALL OF MY TEAMS
HERE THAT WORK ON WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. THAT INCLUDES THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD EMPLOYMENT TRAINING POINT
PANEL THE WORK FOR SERVICES
BRANCH. THEY ARE ALREADY THE
COME TOGETHER TO TALK ABOUT
WORKFORCE STRATEGY AND MY
COMMITMENT MY GOAL IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE WORKING. VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEIR NEEDS ARE AND TO INVEST
TRAINING DOLLARS AND PROGRAMS
WHERE THEY'RE NEEDED MOST AND
ALSO IN A WAY THAT INTEGRATES
WITH OUR GOALS FOR DEVELOPING
ENOUGH. YOU KNOW OUR HEALTH CARE
ECONOMY OUR CLIMATE
SUSTAINABILITY ECONOMY AND ALL
OF THESE NEW- AN UPCOMING
INDUSTRIES THAT WE HOPE TO BRING
INTO THE STATE. AND SO THAT IS
MY GOAL AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING MORE WITH YOU ON THIS
ISSUE BECAUSE- THIS IS WHAT
MAKES US RELEVANT OR IRRELEVANT
HOW WELL WE CAN MEET THE NEEDS
OF INDIVIDUALS SUCH AS THOSE IN
YOUR DISTRICT. THANK YOU AND YOU
KNOW WHAT I COULDN'T AGREE WITH
YOU MORE YES THAT BUILDING IS
JANKY. BUT YEAH I'VE HEARD
THROUGH THE GRAPEVINE THAT THE
STATE HAS THE MONEY SO I'M GOING
TO CROSS MY FINGERS THAT THAT
GREAT PUT ON SOMEBODY'S WISH
LIST. BUT ULTIMATELY YOU'RE
RIGHT THIS IS. HOW DO WE CREATE
EFFECTIVE CONNECTIVITY. BETWEEN
THE SERVICES IN THE RESOURCES
AND THE SUPPORT THAT WE OFFER AS
A STATE. AND A CALIFORNIANS WHO
NEED IT SO- I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING YOU WHEN THE TIME IS
RIGHT AND THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR.
THANK YOU- SENATOR COME LONGER
AND- THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
ANSWERS THUS FAR I PROBABLY
DON'T HAVE MANY QUESTIONS BUT- I
DID WANT TO ASK- ABOUT. YOUKNOW
AS WE GO FORWARD WE HAD A
RECESSION WHEN I WE WERE COMING
OUT OF A RECESSION WHEN I GOT
ELECTED. TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
TWENTY TEN AND WE HAD TO PULL
TOGETHER ADDITIONAL STAFF TO
HANDLE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
CLAIMS BEFORE WE HAD TO CREATE A
STRIKE TEAMIS YOU KNOW WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE RESOURCES WE
HAVE TODAY. TO KIND OF DO THAT
BUT OF COURSE TODAY WE HAVE
WORKFORCE ISSUES- JUST ACROSS
THE BOARD AS I'M SURE YOU'RE
MORE THAN AWARE OF. SO SB THREE
NINETY I DIDN'T REALIZE IT WAS
YOU WERE SENATOR EARLIER BUT-
REQUIRES EDT TO DEVELOP A
RECESSION PLAN TO PREPARE FOR AN
INCREASE IN UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE COMPENSATION BENEFITS
CLAIMS WHEN THERE'S AN ECONOMIC
RECESSION. NOW LAST TIME WAS NOT
QUITE LIKE WE ARE EXPERIENCING
THIS TIME SO YOU MIGHT THINK
GOING FORWARD WILL OF COURSE
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO HANDLE
RECESSION AND HAVE A BETTER PLAN
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN SO
OVERWHELMED AT THIS TIME. HOW
COULD WE NOT HAVE A YOU KNOW
KIND OF COVERED THE BASE FOR A
FUTURE RECESSION THAT PROBABLY
WOULD IN NO WAY MATCH THIS ONE
BUT I JUST KINDA WANT TO SENSE
OF YOUR PERSPECTIVE
UNDERSTANDING YOU'RE STILL. ALL
THIS HOW ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT
THE NEXT TOM AND GIVE ME YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT AND HOW YOU'RE
PROCEEDING FORWARD TO KIND OF
PUT THAT IN PLACE SO WE DON'T
HAVE A NEXT TIME TO THIS. DEGREE
I'M CENTER YOU THANK FOR YOUR
CALL. YOU KNOW FOR ME ONE OF THE
DANGERS- THAT WE HAVE IN
GOVERNMENT MANY TIMES IS SORT OF
AND LEISURE OF WHAT HAPPENED
BEFORE. AND SO WHEN WE BOUNCE
BACK. AND THINGS NORMALISE AND
WE'RE IN WHAT WE CALL SORT OF
THE STEADY STATE OPERATIONS WE
OFTEN BEGIN TO EITHER BECAUSE
THERE IS A NEED TO CUT BACK. ON
FUNDING OR BECAUSE THEY WERE RE
PRIORITIZATION. WE START CUTTING
BACK ON THE INVESTMENTS THAT WE
NEED. IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
MEET THE DEMANDS THAT WERE
CAUSED BY A RECESSION. SO THAT
TO ME IS ONE OF THE DANGERS THAT
WE NEED TO AVOID AS WE ARE
COMING OUT. OF THIS RECESSION
AND WORKING THROUGH THIS
CONTINUE. WORKLOAD THAT WE HAVE
AN EDT. THE OTHER THING THAT I
WOULD SAY IS ALL OF THESE
LESSONS LEARNED THEY DO HAVE TO
BE CAPTURED IN A RECESSION
PLANET SO I THINK SENATOR
LAYERED. YOU THE SENATE BILL AND
FOR THIS REQUIREMENT TO HAVE A
RECESSION PLAN FOR THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM.
CURRENTLY UNDER REVIEW AND WERE
EXPECTED THAT IT WILL BE- IN
YOUR HANDS TIMELY OF BY MARCH
FIRST AS REQUIRED BY THE BILL-
MANY OF THE LESSONS LEARNED. OUR
OUR OUR PIECES THAT WE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN AND
THAT WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK THROUGH BASED ON THE STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE GOVERNOR
STRIKE- STRENGTH TEAM. AND A LOT
OF IT HAS TO DO WITH TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZING OUR TECHNOLOGY SO
THAT IT IS MORE NIMBLE SO THAT I
CAN ADAPT TO CHANGING NEEDS AND
REQUIREMENTS AND THE OTHER PIECE
OF IT IS. THE ABILITY TO QUICKLY
STAFF ALL AND YOU KNOW WHAT THE
PLANS ARE AROUND THAT SO THOSE
TWO PIECES- TO GATHER ARE THE
KEY BETTER ACCESS TO OUR SYSTEMS
BETTER CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE WHEN
THEY INTERACT WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY AND MODERNIZATION
OVERALL ALONG WITH A STAFFING
PLAN THAT WILL HELP US STOP OFF
WHEN THESE CRISES HIT AGAIN
WHICH OF COURSE THEY WILL. WE
WANT TO LEAVE EDT AND THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM
MUCH BETTER OFF THAN IT WAS UP
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THANK YOU
FOR THAT I THINK THAT'S OUR
INCREDIBLE HOPE I YES HOPEFULLY
BECAUSE OF THE BILL. A
REQUIREMENTS BUT ALSO- YOU SEEM
TO HAVE BEEN AN IN DEPTH
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THAT MEANS
I APPRECIATED- AND YOU ANSWER TO
OTHER QUESTIONS IN THAT SO OFTEN
I'LL SKIP THOSE QUESTIONS- BUT I
DO WANT TO ASK ABOUT. WHAT ONE
OTHER PIECE OF THAT MORE THAN
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION P. WAY
RECIPIENTS I'M TOLD. RECEIVED A
REMINDER NOTICES FROM ED'S TO
SUBMIT THEIR PROOF OF SELF
EMPLOYMENT AS REQUIRED BY THE.
PROVIDE REGARDING FOR ANY OTHER
GUIDANCE THAT WE'VE GOTTEN FROM
THE US DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
AROUND THIS OVER OVER PAYMENTS
HOW ARE WE GOING TO. ADDRESS
THAT YES SO YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE US
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR. ON ALL OF
THE PANDEMIC OF UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE SUPPORT THAT WAS
PROVIDED. AND SO OUR REACHING
OUT TO CLAIMANTS TO PROVIDE
EVIDENCE THAT THEY WERE YOU KNOW
UNEMPLOYED AND SEEKING WORK WAS
FOLLOWING FROM DOL'S GUIDANCE.
ON THE OVERPAYMENT ISSUE WHICH
WHICH IS SEPARATE AND DIFFERENT
WE HAVE NOT YET BE GONE ANY OF
OUR WORK OVERPAYMENTS OF
COLLECTION PROCESS WHAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY DOING IS WORKING WITH
DEAL WELL. ON OPTIONS FOR
WEAVERS FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO.
WE'RE NOT FRAUDULENT AND WHO
WERE NOT AT FAULT AND MIGHT HAVE
RECEIVED MORE THAN THEY
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE- AND SO FAR
DEAL HAS RESPONDED AND THE
PROVIDED AT SEVEN OPTIONS FOR
WEAVERS- AND WE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM TO SEE HOW WE WOULD
IMPLEMENT THOSE AND WHAT OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES THERE MIGHT BE TO
WAVE. OVER PAYMENTS THAT ARE DUE
TO NON FRAUD AND NON FAULT AS
WELL. AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU KNOW WE ARE WE ARE
DOING THIS RIGHT AND THAT- WE
ARE. YOU KNOW. ARENA OF ALL OF
THE FACTORS THAT WERE IN PLACE
WHEN HE WAY WENT OUT. THANK YOU
FOR THAT I AM PRETTY SURE THAT
AS AS WE LOOK AT THAT ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION A REMINDER NOTICES
THAT MANY OF OUR STAFFS ARE
GOING TO. BE PART OF THAT
PROCESS AND I DO WANT TO SAY HOW
MUCH I APPRECIATE EVEN IS
OVERWHELMED AND DIFFICULT AS IT
HAS BEEN. THE STAFF AND ET DE
HAVE RESPONDED TO OUR QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS- IT HASN'T BEEN
EASY BUT- I DO APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT- I IT YOU KNOW ONE THING
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE. IS THE WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION PRIORITY INITIATIVE
AND I WONDERED IF YOU WANTED TO
GIVE ME JUST OF A SHORT GLIMPSE
OF HOW THAT SEEMS TO BE GOING IN
AN UPDATE ON EFFORTS AS IT
RELATES TO THE APPRENTICESHIP
MODEL. INTO NEW SECTORS. YES I
THINK THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION AND THIS IS ONE THAT
I'M VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT AND
VERY INVOLVED IN. A WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH VR A WITH THE
DIRECTOR THERE AS WELL AS OUR
DIVISION OF APPRENTICESHIP
STANDARDS. SO WE ARE CURRENTLY
PLANNING OUT. WHAT THAT FUNDING-
COULD GO FORWARD AND WE HAVE
SEVERAL IDEAS AROUND- INNOVATIVE
PRACTICES IN THE TRADES THAT
BRING MORE WOMEN IN- WE ARE
CONSIDERING SUPPORT SERVICES
THAT WOMEN NEED. TO FINISH THEIR
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS- AND
EVEN ACCESS THOSE PROGRAMS. AND
WE'RE ALSO VERY MUCH LOOKING I-
BROUGHT ANY NOT. TRAINING SO
TRAINING FOR WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION AROUND SAFETY AND
HEALTH- AND OTHER ISSUES AROUND
MENTOR SHIP AND BEING ABLE TO
HAVE A VOICE IN A WORKPLACE THAT
TRADITIONALLY. DOESN'T INCLUDE A
LOT OF WOMEN WHICH CAN BE VERY
INTIMIDATING FONG. I WILL SAY IN
YOU KNOW IN THE FALL I WAS ABLE
TO VISIT WITH MANY OF OUR PRE
APPRENTICESHIP AND
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. ACROSS
THE STATE AND THEY ARE JUST
AMAZING OPPORTUNITIES UP FOR
PEOPLE YOU KNOW OF ALL WALKS OF
LIFE. TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
MEANINGFUL CAREERS. WITH VAULT
IN A WORKPLACE. BUT WHAT IS
LACKING IS CLEARLY WOMEN AND SO
I. ALWAYS MENTION THIS- TO
THROUGH THE TRADES AND THEY ARE
TAKING THIS VERY SERIOUSLY AND
THEY ARE ALSO. ARE CONSIDERING
WAYS THAT THEY CAN BE MORE
INNOVATIVE PARTICULARLY IN THE
RECRUITMENT. OF WOMEN AND THE
SUPPORT OF THOSE AND THAT WOMEN
ONCE THEY ENTER THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. AND
COMPLETE THOSE PROGRAMS. WE I'M
THREE TO HEAR YOUR HAVE ABOUT
THIS I KNOW NUMBER MY COLLEAGUES
ARE GOING TO WANT TO HAVE
UPDATES ON IT. MOVING FORWARD
AND AS WE LOOK AT MARCH WHICH IS
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH. I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING TO REALLY
HIGHLIGHT BECAUSE DEFINITELY-
IT'S AN IMPORTANT ASPECT OF
EXPANDING THE WORK FORCE- I. YOU
KNOW I THINK. ALL OF THE
QUESTIONS ARE I COULD PROBABLY
ASK MORE BUT BECAUSE I'M
INTERESTED AND- YOU SEEM TO
REALLY HAVE YOUR FINGER ON THE
PULSE I AGREE WITH THE VICE
CHAIR. ON WHAT YOU'RE UP AGAINST
AND THEN THE MONUMENTAL TASK ON
THESE DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS THAT
YOU OVERSEE BUT YOU KNOW LEAST-
LEASE THE YOU THINK WE DON'T
READ YOUR MATERIALS AND YOUR BIO
I DID HAVE ONE INTERESTING
QUESTION I JUST HAD TO ASK. I IN
READING THE BIO. BUT YOU SAY
THAT WHILE SMALL URUGUAY WAS THE
FIRST EVER WORLD SOCCER WINNER
IN NINETEEN THIRTY AYE YOU KNOW
I DON'T KNOW. I DON'T KNOW IF
ANY OF YOU FOLLOW SOCCER I LOVE
IT. I FIND IT INTERESTING AND
MAYBE YOU CAN ENLIGHTEN US R. AS
TO WHY THIS IS THAT WHILE
URUGUAY IS SUCH A STOP SMALL
TINY COUNTRY OF LIKE THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION PEOPLE. THAT THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY SEEMS TO HAVE
A DISPROPORTIONATELY LARGE
NUMBER. HI URUGUAY AMERICAN
STAFF TO EITHER WORK OR HAVE
WORKED THERE. I MEAN I'M A
FAMILIAR THAT ARE PRO PREVIOUS-
GOVERNOR BROWN'S UNDER SECRETARY
OF THE LABOR SECRETARY YOU'VE
GOT AGENTS YOU MAY REMEMBER.
FORMER SECRETARY OVER THERE. A
SON OF URUGUAY IMMIGRANTS AND
ALSO AN AVID FOOTBALL FAN. I
KNOW THIS BECAUSE HIS PARTNER IS
THE PERSON WHO IS THE SECRETARY
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND WHO KEEPS
ME ON TASK DURING THIS HEARING.
WHICH TYPICALLY SHE IS NOT DOING
QUESTION BUT- I JUST WANT YOU TO
EXPLAIN THAT TO ME- ARE YOU ARE
YOU IMPORTING- TALENT FROM.
OTHER COUNTRIES IN WHICH TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA BE MORE SUCCESSFUL.
YEAH I MEAN I THINK I HAVE A
PRETTY GOOD ANSWER AND I LOVE
THIS QUESTION AND YOU KNOW AND I
DON'T I HIGHLIGHT YOUR BOY IN MY
BIO BECAUSE- MANY PEOPLE NEVER
HEAR ABOUT URUGUAY AND SO I DO
LOVE YOU KNOW TALKING ABOUT WHY
IT'S FOR MY PARENTS ARE FROM MY-
MY ENTIRE FAMILY SO. YOU KNOW.
WHYIS A COUNTRY OF IMMIGRANTS
IT'S VERY FULLER TO THE UNITED
STATES IT IS A COUNTRY OF
IMMIGRANTS AND SO YES IT WASN'T
IMPORTER. OF A LOT OF EUROPEANS-
THAT CAME WITH AN ADDED A
PASSION FOR SOCCER AND SO I
THINK THAT'S YOU KNOW SIMILAR TO
ARGENTINA THAT'S WHERE THE
TRADITION AND THE PASSION COMES
FROM. I WOULD ALSO- WE'RE SEEING
WHICH IS A AND THAT MIGHT ANSWER
WHY THERE HASN'T BEEN A
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF- YOUR
WINDS ARE YOU KNOW CHILDREN OF
YOUR LINES HERE- URUGUAY IS A
VERY. PROGRESSIVE COUNTRY AND
IT'S VERY CONNECTED UP TO THE
WORLD IN TERMS OF ARTS AND
ECONOMY AND- IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S
EDUCATION SYSTEM. AND SO WHILE
IT HAS THREE AND A HALF OR SO
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY I
BELIEVE THERE ARE ABOUT ANOTHER
MILLION AND A HALF OUTSIDE OF
THE COUNTRY. ARE DOING GREAT
THINGS. SO I HOPE THAT ANSWER-
IS A LITTLE BIT. I IT'S GREAT TO
ALWAYS MORE I YOU KNOW ABOUT THE
WORLD BECAUSE CAN BE AND THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD YEAH WE TEND TO BE
RECEIVED BY OTHER COUNTRIES AS
IF WE WERE MEMBERS OF PARLIAMENT
OR CONGRESS WHICH IS A LITTLE
ODD- TO SAY THE LEAST BUT- I'VE
BEEN TREATING SENATOR LAYERED I
CAN ONLY IMAGINE THE- QUESTION
OR PROBLEM. WELL THERE ARE WAS.
ADMONISHED BY THE SECRETARY IN
OUR MEETING FOR DESCRIBING HOW I
HAD BEEN IN BUENOS IRIS ONCE AND
WALKED BY. THE FERRY TO
MONTEVIDEO AND DIDN'T GET ON IT.
SO SHE WAS- LET ME KNOW THAT I'D
REALLY MADE THE WRONG DECISION-
RUNNING OUT ON THE RECORD AND
LET ME AS LONG AS I'M- TALKING.
IT THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM FOR
THE FACT THAT I DIDN'T BRING UP
MY BILL YOU DID IT AND THAT IS
THAT IS WONDERFUL AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THE
SECRETARY. KNOWS THAT THE BILL
SPECIFIED TO REPORT FOR MARCH
FIRST AND WE'RE GETTING VERY
CLOSE TO IT SO. I APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU ABSOLUTELY CENTER
WE HAVE MANY WAYS TO ASK
QUESTIONS AND FIND OUT WHAT-
WHAT WHAT YOU'RE AWARE OF AND
SO- I. AM THRILLED THAT SENATOR
GROW WAS ABLE TO REJOIN IS WHAT
I'M BUYING A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
SO SHE CAN GET GROUNDED TO ASK
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
AND APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
SHE'S DOING DOUBLE DUTY OUT
WE'VE JUST FINISHED UP WITH A
AROUND OF QUESTIONS FROM FROM
EVERYONE BUT WANT TO GIVE YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY CENTER GROVE TO
ASK A QUESTION OR MAKE COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MADAM FOR TEN AND IT'S
VERY NICE TO SEE YOU AGAIN I
ENJOYED OUR CONVERSATION THAT WE
HAD- THEY'VE FOR YESTERDAY A
BELIEVER SOMETHING I DON'T
REMEMBER FRIDAY. MAYBE THURSDAY
OR FRIDAY I APPRECIATE THAT I
THOUGHT AND WE THOUGHT IT WAS
VERY ENGAGING AND I REALLY
APPRECIATED. AND YOUR RESPONSES
AND SO WELCOME TO CALIFORNIA I
KNOW YOU CAN FROM THE EAST COAST
AND WELCOME TO CALIFORNIA. AND
ALL THIS ASK YOU A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- I'M SURE THEY WERE
ALREADY ASKED BY. SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES I APOLOGIZE THAT I
WAS IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE FOR A
BRIEF PERIOD OF TIME. AND YOU
KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT THE U. I
TRUST FUND WHICH IS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT CENTER YOUR PURVIEW.
AND DAD IT'S A SUBSTANTIAL
DOLLAR AMOUNTAND EMPLOYERS-
WERE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
LAST YOU I TRUST FUND OVERDRAFT.
AND IT TOOK SEVERAL YEARS I
BELIEVE SIX YEARS TO PAY IT BACK
IT WAS SUBSTANTIAL- AT THE END
OF EVERY YEAR YOU WOULD JUST GET
A BILL IN WITHIN THREE WEEKS YOU
HAVE TO PRODUCE ANOTHER HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR- WHATEVER IT
WAS. AND SOME BUSINESSES REALLY
STRUGGLE WITH THAT. BUT YOU HAD
A VERY BALANCED APPROACH TO THE
U. I TRUST THAT I KNOW THE
GOVERNOR HAS RESOURCES IN THE
BUDGET THIS YEAR. TO COVER THE
OVERDRAFT PAYMENT FOR THIS YEAR
BUT THEY'RE STILL PROBABLY
TWENTY YEARS IN FRONT OF US SO
WHAT'S YOUR LONG TERM PLAN-
THOUGHTS ON THE U. I TRUST FUND
. THANK YOU SENATOR VERY MUCH
AND I ALSO ENJOYED OUR
CONVERSATION. VERY MUCH AND SO I
THANK YOU ALSO FOR THE WELCOME.
YES WE DID TALK A LITTLE BT
ABOUT THIS BUT I WILL. REITERATE
SOME OF WHAT I SAID. THE
GOVERNOR'S YOU KNOW THREE POINT
ONE BILLION OF TOWARD THE
FEDERAL DEBT THAT IS OWED. OF
FOR OUR E. U. I. TRUST FUND IS
SIGNIFICANT AND- IT SHOWS THAT.
YOU KNOW HE IS WITH EMPLOYERS HE
UNDERSTANDS THIS BURDEN. OF THAT
CONTINUES TO OCCUR EVERY TIME.
THERE IS AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN-
IN OUR STATE. AND THE TRUST FUND
BECOMES INSOLVENT AND WE HAVE TO
GO OUT AND BORROW. WHAT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I MENTIONED.
EARLIER AND- AND I BELIEVE THIS
WAS ADDRESSING SENATOR BEATS
QUESTION ABOUT THE SAME TOPIC.
WAS THAT THERE ARE DIFFERENT
WAYS TO. APPROACH AND THINK
ABOUT THE U. I TRUST FUNDS. AND
THERE ARE MANY MODELS OUT THERE-
FROM OTHER STATES AND WHAT THEY
HAVE DONE. THAT WE COULD LOOK
AT. AND SO WHEREAS WE MIGHT BE
BUCKET MORE. IN THE CATEGORY OF
A PAY AS YOU GO STATE. WE DON'T
COLLECT THAT MUCH UP FRONT. AND
THEN UNFORTUNATELY WHEN WE HAVE
RECESSIONS. WE END UP HAVING TO-
TAX EMPLOYERS TO COVER THAT
DEBT. THERE ARE OTHER MODELS.
THERE ARE MODELS THAT THINK MORE
ABOUT FORWARD FUND. A LITTLE
MORE AND YOU'RE YOU'RE A HAVE A
BETTER AT RISK. SO THAT YOU HAVE
. THIS US IN AND- DURING. AND
THERE ARE EVEN MODELS THAT GO
WAY BEYOND THIS WHERE THERE
CALPERS CYCLICAL AND THEY BUILD
UP VERY LARGE RESERVES. AND
ACTUALLY TRY TO REDUCE THE TAX
BURDEN ON EMPLOYERS. WHEN THERE
ARE RECESSIONS AND WHEN THEY MAY
NEED THAT TAX RELIEF THE MOST SO
ALL TO SAY THERE ARE MANY MODELS
AND WE ARE HERE TO HELP. ARE YOU
AND YOUR COLLEAGUES AS YOU THINK
THROUGH THIS ISSUE UP WITH
ANALYSIS DISCUSSIONS WITH OTHER
STATES- EXAMPLES OF WHAT IS OUT
THERE OR EVEN ANALYSIS ON HOW
CHANGES COULD IMPACT. THE STATE
AND OUR EMPLOYERS. THANK YOU AM
I KNOW AND THAT WAS YOU BROUGHT
UP SOMETHING THAT WE DIDN'T- I
DON'T RECALL DISCUSSING IT ABOUT
TAXING EMPLOYERS MORE AND
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS THE
HIGHEST I MEAN WE'RE ACTUALLY-
ALMOST 5% HIGHER THAN ANY OTHER
STATE SO TO INCREASE HER IS
AGAIN. DOESN'T SEEM LIKE A
VIABLE SOLUTION- I'D I'D LIKE
AND I DON'T RECALL THAT BEING
ONE OF THE RESPONSES THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT LAST WEEK BUT I'M
GLAD THAT YOU WERE ABLE TO BRING
THAT TO MY ATTENTION TODAY. AND
AT THAT CAN I APPLAUD THE
GOVERNOR FOR THE THREE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS THAT HE ALLOWED
FOR A PAYMENT AND TO HELP WITH
THE SITUATION THAT WAS CAUSED.
AN OVER THE PANDEMIC PERIOD FOR
THAT YOU I TRUST FUND TO BE-
INSOLVENT A I APPRECIATE YOUR
RESPONSE I HAVE- ANOTHER
QUESTION THAT I WANT TO TALK TO
THAT WE BRIEFLY TALKED ABOUT THE
ELLERBEE THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD. THAT TAKES ON
ISSUES- WAGING OUR ISSUES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT FOR FARMWORKERS
AND THEY'RE KIND OF UNDER YOUR
PURVIEW BUT NOT REALLY THERE AN
INDEPENDENT- BOARD BUT THEY HAVE
SOME TYPE OF OVERSIGHT THROUGH
THE DEEP AS SECRETARY OF LABOR
TRUE OR NOT TRUE. YES SO THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
BORDER AT THE A. R. B. E. IS AN
INDEPENDENT BOARD THAT FALLS
UNDER- THE LABOR FAMILY OF
GROUPS OF PANELS BOARDS AND
DEPARTMENTS WE SAY IT'S
INDEPENDENT BECAUSE IT'S
DECISIONS WHEN THERE ARE CASES
BROUGHT TO THE BOARD ARE
INDEPENDENCE OF MY INFLUENCE FOR
ALL OF THE GOVERNOR'S INFLUENCE
SO YOU HAVE THE THESE ARE
INDEPENDENT- DECISIONS THAT'S
WHAT THAT'S- WHY IT IS AWARD.
HOWEVER THE ROLE OF THE LRB IS
SPECIFICALLY IN THE SPACE OF
LABOR- RELATIONS WITHIN THE
AGRICULTURAL OF LANDSCAPE. SO IT
IS NOT. LIKE D. DIVISIONS WHICH
ARE FOLK ON SAFETY AND HEALTH.
AS WELL AS WE AND OUR AND
OVERTIME. AND RETALIATES. SO IT
IS A VERY SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED
ON. LABOR RELATIONS- ISSUES AND
PROCESSES FOR WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS IN THE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY. SO I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE
SEPARATE FROM THE SECRETARY OF
LABOR'S AT. OVERSIGHT NEAR
DECISIONS ARE SEPARATE FROM ME
YES OF COURSE THEY ARE
INTEGRATED TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
EVER WANT TO THINK ABOUT YOU
KNOW SUPPORTING EMPLOYERS IN A
DIFFERENT WAY OR WORKERS THEY
WOULD KNOW ABOUT IT-
PARTICULARLY IF IT HAS TO DO
WITH THE AGRICULTURAL SPACE THEY
THOUGHT THEY DON'T FOCUS ON THE
SAFETY HEALTH OR WAGES AND HOURS
ARE CONDITIONS OF WORK ISSUES
THAT OUR DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS OVERSEAS.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT WE TALKED EXTENSIVELY ABOUT
PART OF THE PRIVATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ACT AND I LEFT YOUR
RESPONSE THAT YOU WERE SURPRISED
AT THAT BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS
THE ONLY STATE THAT HAS THAT
TYPE OF LIFE HE DID SAY I THINK
TWO OR THREE OTHER STATES ARE
LOOKING AT IT. AND THAT AT THAT
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY ONE THAT
HAS THE TIMETHAT. PRIVATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ACT- LAW IN
EXISTENCE. THERE IS A BALLOT
MEASURE ON THE BALLOT THE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FAIR PAY EMPLOYER
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. OF WHICH
WOULD- IN ADDITION TO REFORM IN
THE PRIVATE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
ACT WHICH HAS HUGE AN INTENSIVE
KERR UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES FOR
BOTH THE EMPLOYEE AND THE
EMPLOYER IT DOES DRASTICALLY
ENTHUSIASTICALLY BENEFIT ALL
TRIAL LAWYERS. BUT YOU KNOW YOU
GO THROUGH THESE LONG PROCESSES
OF A LOT OF THIS LITIGATION AND
THE EMPLOYEES ARE GETTING YOU
KNOW I KNOW IN CASE WE GOT LIKE
THREE DOLLARS EACH IN A DOLLAR
FIFTY EACH AND THE EMPLOYER PAID
OUT MULTI MILLIONS OF DOLLARS-
IN THE ATTORNEY KIND OF WALKED
AWAY WITH A HUGE PORTION-
SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS OF THESE
CASES IS THE GENERAL WAY HAPPENS
WHICH CAUSED. US IS THE
LEGISLATURE TO RESPOND IN ACTED
BRING SETTLEMENTS TO THE DIR AND
VENDA DIR SO THERE WERE
SETTLEMENTS COULD BE REVIEWED SO
THAT THE D. I. R. COULD STEP IN
AND SAY NO MISTER ATTORNEY
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET A
MILLION WELL THESE MILLION
DOLLARS WHILE THESE EMPLOYEES
GET. A DOLLAR FIFTY OR WHATEVER
THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT IS. SO
IF OR SHOULD THIS BALLOT MEASURE
PASS AND IT WOULD BRING MORE
RESPONSIBILITY LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE SO IF IT
DOES PASS SHOULD IT PASS HAVE
YOU GIVEN ANY THOUGHT ON HOW
THIS WOULD IMPACT THE AGENCY AND
SPECIFICALLY THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE- BECAUSE.
IF IT DOES PASS IT WOULD TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE EVALUATING
AND WE NEED TO CONTINUOUSLY
ASSESS- YOU KNOW WE ABSOLUTELY
DISCUSS PAGA AND I AM VERY
COGNIZANT OF SOME OF THE
PERVERSE INCENTIVES AND THE
UNINTENDED SORT OF CONSEQUENCES
AND ACTIONS THAT COME OUT OF
THIS ACT- AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE CAN BE HELPFUL IN PROVIDING
INFORMATION TO YOU TO
UNDERSTAND. HOW OUR WORK MAY
LOOK DIFFERENT IF THIS BALLOT
INITIATIVE PASSES WE ARE HERE TO
DO THAT- AND WE ARE HAPPY TO
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS- TO
INFORM YOU AS THE POLICYMAKERS
ON YOU KNOW ANY ANYTHING ELSE-
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE. SO WE ARE
HERE TO DISCUSS THAT WITH YOU
AND WALK YOU KNOW. WITH YOU ON
THAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR QUESTIONS IT WAS
REALLY A PLEASURE TO SPEND IT
WAS A PLEASURE ALMOST AN HOUR
WITH YOU I FELT BAD- SO ALMOST
AN HOUR WITH YOU THE OTHER DAY
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONFIRMATION IWISH YOU THE BEST
OF LUCK. I THINK I AM- YOU KNOW.
THE PRIOR SECRETARY OF LABOR
THAT WE HAD- I KNOW SHE WENT ON
TO WHAT WOULD BE WHAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED BIGGER AND BETTER
THINGS AND THE DC LEVEL OR THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. BUT I APPRECIATE
YOUR AT LEAST WILLINGNESS
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO WILLINGNESS
ON THE OTHER YOU KNOW THE LABOR
SECRETARY. TO EVEN EXPLORE OR
LOOK AT THE ADVERSE. AT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE PRIVATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ACT ON BOTH
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR OPENNESS TO EVEN
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND ON THE U. I TRUST
FUND ISSUE AND HOW- YOU KNOW HOW
THAT DESPERATELY NEEDS TO BE
RESOLVED. I JUST APPRECIATED ALL
YOUR REMARKS AND YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO LOOK AT BOTH
SIDES AND BE FAIR BALANCE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOUR
CONFIRMATION. WELL THANK YOU
SENATOR GROVE AND IT WAS A
PLEASURE SPEAKING WITH YOU TOO
AND- YOU KNOW JUST UNDERSTANDING
THE CONCERNS OF THE CHARGES
FACED BY OUR SMALL BUSINESSES ON
OUR BUSINESSES. ARE BROADLY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT FOR THAT
INSIGHT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR GROWTH AND THANK YOU
SECRETARY WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
TO PEOPLE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY. AND WE'RE GONNA
START WITH MEMBERS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. AND BEFORE
WE START RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. I'M GOING
TO DO A REMINDER FOR WITNESSES
WISHING TO PROVIDE COMMENT. VIA
PHONE THAT WE HAVE OF TOLL FREE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX
THREE. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
SEVEN ONE SEVEN SIX EIGHT TWO
SIX. AND WITH THAT LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK. IN SUPPORT- I DON'T
SEE ANYONE- APPROACHING THE
PODIUM. SO WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE- AND I
WILL WELCOME THE MODERATOR AND
BUT AS I DO THAT I WILL JUST SAY
TO THE WITNESSES WHO WILL BE IN
THE QUEUE TO SPEAK. THAT WE NEED
YOU TO PROVIDE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION IF ANY. THE
POSITION ON THE APPOINTMENT AND
WE ARE TAKING- MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT RIGHT NOW. AND
ON BEHALF OF OUR COURT REPORTER
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY. AND WITH THAT LET
ME WELCOME THE MODERATOR TO THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO. OR
PRESS THE ONE THEN ZERO NOW
AGAIN THIS IS FOR SUPPORT WE DO
HAVE THREE IN THE QUEUE WE'LL GO
TO LINE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON- MEDICAL
CAM THEN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHRISTY BALANCE I AM SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND I
AM PLEASED TO BE SPEAKING TODAY
IN SUPPORT. OF THE CONFIRMATION
OF. A MYSTERY YEAH HI PRACTICING
THE NAME AS WELL MAN PRETEND
AND- AN OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH
. WITH SECRETARY. LOOK FOR THE
WORKING WITH HER ON ISSUES OF
WORKERS. THE PARTNERSHIP AND PRE
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING IN THE
FIRE SERVICE. THANKS FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. MAXIMAL TO LINE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI IS THE
SENATE RULES YES IT IS GO AHEAD. HOW ECCENTRIC THE TECHNOLOGY
IS JUST SO CONFUSING IN THE
AGENDA AND BRIDGES FOR PLEX
BECAUSE THERE'S SOME OF US
WANTING TO OPPOSE THE SCOTT AND
PAN THE WINNERS CAN'T DEAL BUT
NOW. WE IT WE'VE ALREADY WITH
THAT I IT'S AN- ITEM HANDLED BY
THE COMMITTEE THE COMMITTEE
VOTED THREE TWO ON THE REFERRAL
SO I CANNOT TAKE YOUR CALL AT
THIS TIME IT IS NOT FOR PUBLIC
DISCUSSION SO I DO THANK YOU FOR
CALLING IN- MADAME MODERATOR WE
YOU PLEASE GO TO THE NEXT
WITNESS. YOUR PHONE WILL NOT
MOVE TO WIND TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES I WANT AYE AND THE
DIRECTOR AND CEO OF HIS ORGAN
FOR POLITICAL QUALITY AND
IMPROVE SUPPORT FOR FIRST BY THE
NAND TECH AND WORK DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY. I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HER ON THE ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
OTHER MATAMATA RAIDER. AT THIS
TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE
KEEL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL
BE BACK WITH YOU PROBABLY
MOMENTARILY SO HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT I WILL NOW TURN TO
PEOPLE WHO MAY WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION STARTING HERE AGAIN
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE-
WE STILL DO NOT HAVE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC- THAT HAVE APPEARED
HERE TO SPEAK SO MADAM MODERATOR
I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD AND COME
BACK TO YOU. FOR PEOPLE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO A
POLLS PRESS ONE AND BEEN ZERO
NOW AGAIN IT TO A POLLS ONE AND
THEN ZERO NOW. AND AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE KEEL
. MAN MODERATOR THANK YOU- WE
WILL TALK WITH YOU A LITTLE
LATER IN THE HEARING SO HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM HER GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM PEOPLE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION I WILL BRING IT BACK.
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR A MOTION. I
WILL LET THE VICE CHAIR MAKE
THAT MOTION THANK YOU US SENATOR
BATES. OF MADAM SECRETARY WILL
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROWTH
HI ROBERT I KAMLAGER. THERE ARE
THERE I FAITH HIGH FAITH I
ATKINS HI ATKINS BY FOR ON CALL
FOR AND WE WILL LEAVE THIS
MATTER OPEN SO THAT SENATOR COM
LONGER CAN WEIGH ON US SECRETARY
POLLUTION GUY I WANT TO SAY
CONGRATULATIONS I ANTICIPATE
GIVEN THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
ENOUGH VOTES AND THAT SENATOR
COM LONGER ALREADY INDICATED SHE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO VOTE AND
SUPPORT THAT THIS WILL MOVE ON
TO THE SENATE FOR CONFIRMATION
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. SO HONORED THANK YOU
AGAINEVERYONE FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. LET ME LOOK TO MY
SECRETARY AND WE WILL TAKE A
FIVE MINUTE BREAK AND BE RIGHT
BACK THANK YOU.
OKAY I'M GONNA
GO AHEAD AND CALL OUR MEETING
BACK TO ORDER I THANK YOU ALL.
FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE NOW ON TO ITEM ONE B.
WHICH IS THE APPOINTMENT OF ANA
M. LASO TO THE DIRECTOR OF
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
OR DGS. WELCOME DIRECTOR LOSS SO
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE BY THE
WAY- IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE YOURSELF ODD KNOWLEDGE
ANYONE THAT MIGHT BE WITH YOU
THAT YOU'D LIKE TO THANK. OUR WE
WELCOME THOSE INTRODUCTIONS AND
THEN IF YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS PLEASE GO RIGHT
AHEAD AND THEY WILL GO DIRECTLY
TO MEMBERS OF THE SENATE SO
WELCOME. THANK YOU- ADAM HAD TEN
GOOD AFTERNOON PREP TIME ATKINS
BASED BATES AND GROW COMMON AND
THEIR WORK IT'S AN HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO BE AT THE HEARING
FOR THE CONFIRMATION OF DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES. ALTHOUGH MY CAREER IN
STATE SERVICE ANOTHER PUBLIC
PUBLIC AGENCIES HAS PREPARED ME
FOR THIS ROLE I DO NOT OVERLOOK
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF BEING THE
FIRST WOMAN AND FIRST LESBIAN
NOT TO BE PERMANENTLY APPOINTED
TO SERVE AS THE DIRECTOR AND
HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY FOR
CONFIRMATION I AM THANKFUL TO
GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR THIS
APPOINTMENT. AND THE SUPPORTER
IN MY LEADERSHIP. I TO SINCERELY
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR THE TIME
TO CONSIDER ME FOR THIS
POSITION. THE HOW I GOT TO THIS
POINT IN MY CAREER IS AS
IMPORTANT AS TO THE WIDE BELIEVE
MY LIFE EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN A
VALUABLE PERSPECTIVE. AS THE
DAUGHTER TO IMMIGRANT PARENTS
WHO CAME FROM MEXICO IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES SIXTIES. I
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO PROVIDE FOR
CHILDREN AND EDUCATION UNINSURED
COLLEGE ACCESS. RUN A SMALL
BUSINESS AND BECOME HOMEOWNERS.
THE IMPORTANCE OF ACCESS TO
INFORMATION EDUCATION FOR PAYING
JOBS AND HEALTHCARE AND THE
ABILITY TO BUDGET FOR OUR
HOUSEHOLD LET ALONE A SMALL
BUSINESS. OR CORNERSTONE
CONVERSATIONS AT THE DINNER
TABLE THROUGHOUT MY UPBRINGING.
AS AN ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS-
MY PARENTS ONLY SPEAK SPANISH
OFTEN OFTEN LOOK TO US THEIR
CHILDREN TO HELP THEM NAVIGATE
THE GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS. THAT OUR
FAMILY RELIED ON. WHETHER MY
PARENTS WERE APPLYING FOR A
SMALL BUSINESS LOAN OR
NAVIGATING THE EDUCATION SYSTEMS
FOR THEIR KIDS. WE WERE ALWAYS
THERE TO HELP. ASSEMBLY ADVOCATE
AND REPRESENT AXIS AND
FAMILIARITY PUBLIC SERVICES WERE
NOT AS EASY OR EVEN READILY
AVAILABLE. WHEN USING THEIR HARD
WORK ETHIC AS THEY MANAGED A
SMALL BUSINESS PROPELLED ME TO
WANT TO PURSUE A CAREER THAT
WOULD HELP ME ADDRESS. THE
INEQUITIES THAT I EXPERIENCE
GROWING UP IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES
AND HUNTINGTON PARK. THE LIMITED
ACCESS TO OPEN SPACE FEW HEALTHY
FOOD OPTIONS HEALTH CARE OR
OTHER SUSTAINABLE ENVIRONMENTS
INSPIRED ME TO PURSUE STUDIES.
THAT WOULD GIVE ME THE SKILL
SETS TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
URBAN POVERTY INEQUITIES. AND
WHILE STUDYING EVERY PLANNING I
FOUND MY CALLING AND WORKING
WITH GOVERNMENT TO CREATE MORE
EQUITABLE ENVIRONMENTALLY
SUSTAINABLE AND USER FRIENDLY
SYSTEMS THAT ALL CITIZENS. COULD
ACCESS. SERENDIPITOUSLY
THROUGHOUT MY CAREER I'VE BEEN
APPLYING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES. AT MANY
INTERSECTING POINTS AND BECAUSE
OF MY LIFE AND CAREER
EXPERIENCES MY PERSPECTIVE OF
HOW I AM LEADING TGS. IS TO
PROMOTE THE HUMAN CENTERED
LEADERSHIP THROUGHOUT THE
ORGANIZATION SO THAT WE ARE
PROVIDE WE ARE FOCUSED ON
PROVIDING ACCESS AND DELIVERING
EQUITABLE AND SUSTAINABLE
RESULTS. I'M ALSO INTENT ON LEAN
IN ORGANIZATION THAT PRIORITIZES
DELIVERING RESULTS IN A TIMELY
COST EFFECTIVE MODELS FOR
CUSTOMERS. PERSONALLY I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK MY PARENTS GUSTAVO
AND YOU LEARN THE LAST SO FOR
ALL THEIR SACRIFICES STRONG
WORTH WORK ETHIC- CONDITIONAL
LOVE FAITH COMMITMENT TO GIVING
MY BROTHER SISTERS AND MYSELF
THE OPPORTUNITIES TO STELLAR
EDUCATION. I WANT TO THANK MY
SIBLINGS GUSTS MARTY LILY ARE
PAVING THE PATH TO HELPING ME
REACH HIGHER EDUCATION. MY
DEEPEST APPRECIATION TO MY LEVEL
HAS BEEN A WHOLE SESSION ON THIS
WHO FIRMLY SUPPORTS ME
ENCOURAGES MY DEDICATION TO
PUBLIC SERVICE. AND TO OUR TWO
CHILDREN OUT ABOUT AGE TEN AND
THE L. H. EIGHT FOR BEING
INCREDIBLY UNDERSTANDING AND
AWESOME CHEERLEADERS OF MY WORK
AT EACH YES FINALLY. I WANT TO
THANK MY VILLAGE OF CHILDHOOD
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS WHO ARE
HELPING US FOR OUR KIDS AS JOSE
AND I PURSUE OUR DEDICATION TO
BEING THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE OPEN COM IN
A WE TO WHO WERE IN SCHOOL WE
WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE SEEN
THEIR SMILE FACES AND
CONGRATULATIONS THAT YOU HAVE A
VILLAGE HELPING TO SUPPORT YOU.
IN THAT ENDEAVOR- LET ME- CENTER
GLARED WOULD YOU LIKE TO KICK US
OFF AGAIN THIS TIME. SURE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- N. R. I HAVE TO
CONFESS THAT THE- I WORKED WITH
THE NOMINATION. NOMINALLY WORK
FOR THE RESOURCES AGENCY IS THE
DIRECTOR OF EXPOSITION PARK IN
LOS ANGELES AND WE WORKED
CLOSELY TOGETHER AND- AND WHILE
. I THINK OF IT- THEY APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT WE HAD A CHANCE TO
MEET YESTERDAY AND I THOUGHT I
WOULD ASK A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT IN THE
FIRST ONE. I SORT OF WAS-
DESCRIBE MY OWN KNOWLEDGE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
OVER TEN YEARS AND IT WAS AS MY
LEGISLATIVE COLLEAGUES WILL
UNDERSTAND I HAD THIS HORRIBLE
EXPERIENCE WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY WHERE THEY MADE ME TAKE
THIS AMENDMENT TO THE BILL AND
THEN THEY VETO THE BILL FOR THE
AMENDMENT THAT MAKE ME TAKE
THEM. IT WAS A VERY DISORGANIZED
DEPARTMENT AND THEN I THINK THAT
IN THE LAST SEVEN OR EIGHT YEARS
IT HAS BECOME COLLABORATIVE IT
ACTUALLY IS HIS OUTCOME ORIENTED
BAND IT HAS BEEN A MAJOR CHANGE
AND MY QUESTION WAS HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO CONTINUE THIS AFFECT OF
MAKING SURE THAT. THAT IT'S NOT
CONTROL DEPARTMENT IT JUST
ALWAYS MINDLESSLY STOPS THINGS
BUT THAT IT IS SOMETHING THAT
WORKS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
STATURE COLLABORATE AND GET
THINGS DONE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER FOR- THAT QUESTION THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME YESTERDAY WHEN
WILL MATCH. OPERATIONALLY DG IS
VERY BROAD HAS MORE THAN TWENTY
OFFICES AND DIVISIONS HAS A VERY
DIVERSE PORTFOLIO. AND OF SOME
OF OUR DEPARTMENTS OR DIVISIONS
WITHIN THE JETS COULD BE THEIR
OWN DEPARTMENTS ON THEIR OWN-
BUT WHEN I GOT TO D. G. S. AND I
SAW ESPECIALLY BECAUSE WE'RE
WORKING IN THE TELEWORK
SITUATION RIGHT. AND WE'RE
MOVING TOWARDS HYBRID THAT THEY
CAN. QUICKLY BECOME VERY SILENT.
AND AS A CONTROL AGENCY. ARE
SOME OF THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR SAID
THEY DON'T HAVE A CHANCE TO
CROSS OLLABORATION CROSS
POLLINATE SOME OTHER TEAMS THAT-
SILO TYPE ENVIRONMENT CAN HAPPEN
VERY QUICKLY. SO I SAW AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING
SUSTAINABILITY. THURMOND AND OUR
REALIST- PORTFOLIO ASK THREE
FOCUS AREAS- I THINK IT'S TIME
THAT THE REALLY FOCUS ON CLIMATE
CHANGE RESILIENCY AND WORKING
ACROSS OUR TWENTY DIVISIONS ON
THIS TOPIC AND SEEING HOW WE CAN
CROSS POLLINATE TEAMS WORK
TOGETHER I HOPE TO- CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD A ONE DGS MINDSET
THAT IS COLLABORATIVE THAT IS
CUSTOMER FOCUSED AND IS- INTENT
ON DELIVERING SERVICES IN A
TIMELY AND EFFECTIVE WAY. OF BUT
ALSO THAT WITHIN THE TEAMS THAT
ARE WORKING ON THESE PROJECTS
THAT THEY REACH ACROSS THE
VIRTUAL AISLE OR VIRTUAL
AFFORDABLE TO ENSURE- THAT WE'RE
LEARNING FROM EACH OTHER AND
THAT WE CONTINUE TO PUT OUR
CUSTOMERS FIRST. WELL I
APPRECIATE THAT RISK AND JUST
KNOW THAT WE ARE. ARE ANXIOUS
THAT THAT HAPPENED- DURING YOUR
TENURE IN THAT THAT YOU CONTINUE
TO COLLABORATE TO BE RESPONSIVE.
I THINK THE OTHER THING THAT WAS
INTERESTING TO ME AND I WANTED
TO ASK YOU ABOUT. IT IS YOU
DESCRIBED THAT WHEN YOU HAD
WORKED. AT SOME POINT FOR THE
LOS ANGELES SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT
YOU HAD TO TAKE PLANS IN A TO
HAVE REVIEWED IN SOME FORM BY
THE VERY AGENCY THAT YOU'RE NOW
HEADING. AND I ASKED YOU IF YOU
WOULD ALWAYS REMEMBER WHAT IT
WAS LIKE TO BE ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE COUNTER. BUT NOW THAT YOU
ARE IN THIS POSITION AND YOU
ANSWERED IT WELL I THOUGHT I'D
GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO ANSWER TO
THE HEARING. ABSOLUTELY AND I
JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND ARE
VERY PROUD OF THAT FOLLOWING MY
CONFIRMATION HEARING- WE ARE
GOING TO BE HEARING FROM I TO
CLEAR HIS. FOR THE DIVISION OF
STATE ARCHITECT THAT SAME
DIVISION THAT- MANY TIMES MY
COLLEAGUES MY FORMER COLLEAGUES
AT LA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND I WALKED OVER PLANS FOR
REVIEW. THE DIVISION OF STATE
ARCHITECTS- HAS REALLY-TRANSFORMED THEIR SERVICES SINCE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THEY'VE
GONE TO FILING ELECTRONICALLY
AND WHAT USED TO TAKE OR WHAT
WAS VERY ONEROUS PROCESS FOR THE
CLIENT BEFORE- AND PROBABLY
LINKED. AND THEN ANTICIPATED A
LOT OF FOLKS HAD TO FILL THAT
INTO THEIR SCHEDULES HE DAY THEY
CAN GO TO AN ONLINE PORTAL. AND
THE DIVISION OF THE ARCHITECTS
PROVIDES A GREAT CUSTOMER HERE
REFUSE TO THEIR CLIENTS TO
ENSURE THAT PLANTS ONCE
DELIVERED AND PUT IN THE QUEUE
ARE IN THE PROPER FORMAT FOR
REVIEW AND CAN. I HAVE A QUICK
TURNAROUND SAID THE PROJECT CAN
MOVE FORWARD TO BED AN OBVIOUSLY
EVENTUALLY CONSTRUCTION. AND SO
IT'S FOR TO IT IS THAT DIVISION
IS THE ARCHITECTS MOVED INTO AN
ONLINE PORTAL IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. TWO YEARS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC SO THEY WERE PRIMED AND
READY LOSER. JUST YOU'RE LUCKY
THAT THEY HAD ALREADY DONE THIS
AND THAT THERE ARE TEAMS HAD
ALREADY LEARNED OF THE PROCESS
AND FOLKS OF WHO ARE THEIR
CUSTOMERS HAVE BECOME ACCUSTOMED
TO THIS. ONLINE DELIVERY METHOD
SO- YOU'LL HEAR MORE FROM MY
STAFF I DECLARE WHO ARE PRESENT
LATER BUT- I THINK- THAT CREDIT
IDEA OF THE LENGTH OF TIME IT
WOULD TAKE TO REVIEW PLANS IS NO
LONGER THERE. AT LEAST I HEAR
FROM FOLKS IN THE INDUSTRY.
THANK YOU AND I JUST APPRECIATED
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE BRINGING
THAT EXPERIENCE INTO YOUR JOB I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOU
WHEN WE GET. THE CHANCE THANK
YOU FOR RESPONDING TO THE
QUESTION. THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR.
THANK YOU. I THINK POLITICAL.
YOU HAVE TO AT THEM OKAY
MEDEVACED I WILL GO TO YOU NEXT. MISTER. WELL DIRECTOR DIRECTOR
OF LAWFUL IS LAWFUL ON
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
NOMINATION OF FOR BEING DIRECTOR
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
FOR A LOOK AT YOUR RESUME VERY
IMPRESSIVE IN IN BECAUSE I
PARTICULARLY NOTICED THAT YOU
WERE INVOLVED WITH THE DESIGN
BUILD I THINK OF THE- DEREGULATE
RIGHT TO DESIGN BUILD INSTITUTE
AND THE REASON I BRING THAT UP-
ONE OF MY FIRST ASSIGNMENTS WAS
PLAYING IN A ON THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY WHERE WE
WERE TRYING TO GET THE- THE
ASPHALT ON THE ROADS THE ROADS
DONE MORE UP MORE QUICKLY AND
THE DESIGN BUILD CONCEPT CAME
AND- IT WAS LIKE A- YOU KNOW
LUNOKHOD TWO MOVING PROJECTS
MORE QUICKLY. SO THAT EXPERIENCE. A VERY IMPRESSIVE TO ME
REALLY. IMPORTANT TO THERE AND
ALL IN THE- WORLD. THANK YOU FOR
THAT- COUPLE QUESTION I DID HAVE
A CHANCE TO MEET PERSONALLY AND
I DO APOLOGIZE BUT YESTERDAY.
WAS ON IT JUST OF KIND OF A
CRAZY DAY ON MY SCHEDULE BUT-
HEARING YOUR PRESENTATION- TO MY
COLLEAGUE. AND DONNA- YOUR
EXPLANATION OF HIS SOME VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUES THERE ARE YOU
TO HAVE A COUPLE THAT HAVEN'T
BEEN COVERED YET AND- ONE CAUGHT
MY EYE IN PARTICULAR BECAUSE I
COME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
WE HAVE THE HOMELESS ISSUE. AS
YOU KNOW AND THE FACT THAT WE'VE
NOT HAD SIGNIFICANT INTEREST
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. TO USE
THE SURPLUS PROPERTY THAT'S BEEN
DECLARED I THINK I'M LOOKING AT
MY NUMBERS HERE TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FOUR PROPERTIES- DIFFER.
THAT WERE REALLY REALLY BE SO
HELPFUL WITH THE WHOLE ISSUE OF
THE HOMELESS IN OUR COMMUNITY.
SO COULD YOU ELABORATE A LITTLE
BIT ON THAT AND WHAT MIGHT BE
DONE WHAT WHAT COULD BE THE
PROCESS TO. INCENTIVIZE
ENCOURAGE THEM TO TAKE A LOOK
AT. THOSE OPPORTUNITIES- AND
WHETHER THERE MIGHT BE A WAY TO
COLLABORATE. OF FOR REGIONFOR
SAY LET FAIL SMALLER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO.
YOU KNOW MOVE FORWARD ON A PIECE
OF PROPERTY THAT MIGHT BE TOO
LARGE BUT CERTAINLY IF THEY CAN
COLLABORATE REGIONALLY THAT
COULD BE HELPFUL. WHO ARE YOU
BUILDING ANY INCENTIVES INTO.
THE THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT MIGHT
BE THERE ALSO THAT THEY WOULD
TAKE A SECOND LOOK. AT THE NOTES
WE GO FORWARD AND THAT'S GOING
TO BE ONE OF THE- MOST IMPORTANT
BUILDING BLOCKS TO. OUR HOME THE
PHONE. SOLUTION THANK YOU VERY
MOISTURE RATES FROM CLASH. AND
THIS IS- SOME THAT PREDATES MY
TIME AT TGS HOW I CAN SPEAK TO
THE X. ORDER. TO THREE TO AND-
THE OFFERING OF THIS HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR PARCELS THAT WERE
DECLARED SURPLUS- IT IS TRUE
THAT NOT SO LONG SO FAR HAVE
BEEN TAKEN UP BY THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS COMMUNITIES
COUNTIES OR CITIES. TO PLACE
SHELTERS SO WE HAVE OTHER
PROGRAMS I HAVE HAD QUITE
SUCCESS- BUT I THINK WHAT
HAPPENS IN AND THIS IS JUST MY-
WHAT I'VE LEARNED AND GLEANED
FROM SPEAKING TO STAFF IS THAT.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MAY BE
LOOKING ATPROPERTIES THAT THE
STATE OFFERED AND THOSE MAY NOT
BE IN THE LOCATIONS ARE VIABLE
OR CLOSE TO OR IN. A IN A-
APPROXIMATE LOCATION TO WHERE
THERE ARE OTHER SERVICES AND SO
THEY MAY GO WITH PROPERTIES THAT
THEY THEMSELVES- I AM INTENT
THOUGH I'M TAKING THE DGS- AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE. USING A HUMAN
CENTERED LEADERSHIP APPROACH BUT
ALSO HUMAN CENTERED DESIGN AND
THAT WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT IS
PROVIDING MORE USER FRIENDLY
INFORMATION FOR THE PUBLIC. SO
ENSURING THAT CERTAIN PORTALS OF
OUR WEBSITE AND INFORMATION THAT
WE ARE SHARING- CAN BE MORE
READILY ACCESSIBLE I THINK YOU
KNOW I YOU BRING UP A REALLY
GREAT IDEA AND- I CAN TAKE THIS
BACK TO MY TEAM TO SEE IF THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY. AN
INTERSECTION WHERE WE CAN
PROMOTE SOME OF THAT SURPLUS-
LIST OF PROPERTIES AND SEE HOW
WE CAN WORK WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND JURISDICTIONS-
ON A SECOND OPPORTUNITY TO SEE
IF THEY WOULD BE INTERESTED IN
ANY OF THE PROPERTIES. WE ARE
OFFERING AT A NOMINAL FEE. THE
GREAT PAPER THE CHILL TAKE OUT
FOR. I WAS THINKING THEIR SON
OFF. FOR REGIONS AND WE CAN CALL
FOR THE CALIFORNIA EXAMPLE WHERE
THERE'S SOMETHING IN A LARGE
PARCELS AND- OF. THE INDIVIDUALS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PARTICIPATE
WITH WHATEVER IS REQUIRED IN
TERMS OF LESS SAFE YOU KNOW A
STARTUP MONEY OR FUNDING IN SOME
SORT TALK. THAT WILL I THINK BE
VERY IMPORTANT INCENTIVE TO THEM
AND ALSO GET PEOPLE WORKING ON.
THE PROBLEM AS A REGIONAL ISSUE
VERSUS CITY BY CITY WHICH IS
KIND OF THE WAY I. LIVE IN SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY IN PARTICULAR AND
CREATED UP A LITTLE A LITTLE BIT
FOR BIT OF DISSENSION-
CERTAINLY- I IDEAS OF MAYBE WE
COULD A LIST OF THOSE PROPERTIES
OF- THEY MAY HAVE BEEN
PUBLICIZED AND SEEN THEM
PERSONALLY BUT I'D LIKE TO TAKE
A LOOK. CERTAINLY FOR MY REGION
AND UP. THAT WAY I CAN.
ENCOURAGE MY LOCAL FIRE EVEN
BEYOND OUT TO A TAKE A LOOK OUT
TO OPPORTUNITIES THAT MIGHT BE
THERE AND REACHING OUT TO. SOME
OF THEIR OTHER COLLEAGUES- IN IN
THE REGION. A QUICK QUESTION ON
THE NO BID CONTRACTS I KNOW THAT
THAT IS BEING. CERTAINLY
COVERED. IN THE MEDIA-
EXTENSIVELY AND I AM I THINK OUR
CONCERN IS IF THERE ARE
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO PROTECT
THE STATE FROM POOR PERFORMANCE
BY A COMPANY THAT'S UNDER. A NO
BID CONTRACT ANY ESPECIALLY IF
DOUBTS ONE THAT GETS RENEWED
WITHOUT ANY REAL OR- YEAH. OVER
ON OUR ANY PER. METRICS WERE
PROVIDED TO ALL WHEN THEY WERE
GIVEN THE CONTRACT AND WHETHER
THEY NOT FOUND. WHETHER THEY
HAVE AVOIDED DOLLARS SOME OF THE
SCANDALOUS PHOTO. REPORTS OF
COMMON A FEW OF THEM I THINK
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT SOME REAL
CONCERN IN AN EMERGING OF.
CREDIBILITY ISSUE- CERTAINLY IN
THE DURING THE PANDEMIC I'M
GOING FORWARD. SO IF YOU ALL
COULD GIVE US SOME IDEA OF WHAT
YOU WILL. BE DOING TO TAKE A
LOOK AT. LET'S SAY A MORE
TRANSPARENT AND ACCOUNTABLE.
PROCESS IF THERE'S GOING TO BE
ON NO BID APPROACHES SOMETIMES.
HAVING SERVED A LITTLE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS. UNDERSTAND THAT
SOMETIMES THE THAT ACTUALLY GETS
THE JOB DONE MORE QUICKLY AND
SOMETIMES THOSE CERTAINLY UNDER
BUDGET. BUT I THINK WE NEED TO
KNOW ON THOSE STANDARDS THAT ARE
THERE AND CERTAINLY- THE
PERFORMANCE METRICS. THAT WERE
MET BEFORE IT'S RENEWED.
CERTAINLY I THINK A VERY
QUESTION I THINK YOU FOR. ASKING
THAT AND- THE WHEN WE HAVE AN
EMERGENCY DESK. AND THERE'S AN
EMERGENCY PROCUREMENT FEET
DEPARTMENT CHARLES. PROCUREMENT
DIVISION- WELL SUPPORT OF THOSE
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE MOVING
FORWARD THE EMERGENCY CONTRACT
BUT WE HAVE PER FOR ALL
PARTICIPATION IN SOME OF THE
TERMS AND CONDITIONS SO I THINK
THAT REFERS TO SOME OF THESE
AUTOMATIC- RENEWALS THAT. OUR
PROCUREMENT DIVISION IN RUNNING
A REGULAR PROCUREMENT FROM SOUP
TO NUTS- WOULD NOT NECESSARILY
INCLUDED WHEN WE DO PROCUREMENT
IN A REGULAR. PROCUREMENT
TIMELINE WE ENSURE THAT THE
SERVICES OR GOODS ARE DELIVERED
PRIOR TO PAYMENT WE ENSURE THAT-
THE BAND AND THE CONTEST IS
TRANSPARENT AND- OUR BUYERS
STATE BUYERS REVIEW- THE VENDORS
BACKGROUND ENSURE THAT THEIR
SOLVENT. ALSO WE HAVE CONTROL
MEASURES IN PLACE AND AS A
CONTROL AGENCY DGS TAKES ABOUT
DELEGATION VERY SERIOUSLY-
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE X. OR C. UNDER
THE VARIOUS EMERGENCIES THAT WE
HAVE BEEN FACED WITH A
INCLUDING. THE UNPRECEDENTED
PANDEMIC- THAT CREATED SUCH HIGH
NEEDS BUT I DO WANT TO ASSURE
YOU THAT OUR PROCUREMENT
DIVISION IS INTENT ON
CONTINUOUSLY FOLLOWING THE
MEASURES AMHERST POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE
TO ENSURE TRANSPARENCY- WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN SEEING SOME OF
THOSE IF YOU COULD- YOU KNOW
FOLLOW UP TIED TO MY OFFICE
PROVIDE ME WITH HOW THOSE
REVIEWS ARE DONE- I THINK THAT
THAT'S THE QUESTION IS WHETHER
THEY REALLY ARE. LOOKING IN
DOUBT THAT SUMMER CRITTERS THAT
HAVE COME IN A COUPLE OF BILLS
THAT HAVE REALLY. HIT THE MEDIA
YEAH AND- WE GET QUESTIONS FROM
HER CONSTITUENTS BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR TAX DOLLARS ARE BEING
SPENT ON THE PHONE CERTAINLY ARE
NOT RIDDLED WITH CONTROVERSY AND
POTENTIAL FRAUD. SO IF YOU WOULD
GET THOSE TO ME THAT WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL BUT I THINK YOU FOR
YOUR RESPONSES AND CERTAINLY
ARE. YOU HAVE A BIG JOB IN FRONT
OF YOU SO- WILL HOPE TO HEAR
BACK ON HOW THINGS ARE GOING ON
IN THE NEAR TERM. IT'S THANK YOU
MADAM VICE SENATOR GROW. THANK
YOU IT'S DEFINITELY A PLEASURE-
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
TO YOU CONGRATULATIONS SIGNED-
BEING THE FIRST THERE ARE A LOT
OF BENEFITS TO THAT- I'M THE
FIRST FEMALE VETERAN THAT'S EVER
SERVED IN THE STATE CAPITAL AND
YOU BEING THE FIRST FEMALE AND
LATINA TO EVER HOLD THIS
POSITION IS TRULY SOMETHING THAT
YOU CAN CHERISH FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME SO.
CONGRATULATIONS ON AND THAT. AT
I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS-
THAT- REGARDING THE NO BID
CONTRACTS THAT ARE BEING ISSUED
NOW AS- THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
THE GOVERNOR IS PUT IN PLACE
THAT STATE OF EMERGENCY AS IT
LINGERS ON THERE'S TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN NO BID STATE
CONTRACTS THAT HAVE BEEN ISSUED-
WHAT OVERSIGHT OR AUDIT PROCESS
DOES DGS HAVE IN PLACE- TO
ENSURE THAT FRAUD WASTE ABUSE IS
THINGS LIKE THAT ARE NOT
OVERLOOKED ENTER THAT BECAUSE
THESE. PROJECTS ARE PRIVATELY
NEGOTIATED I GUESS AND IS THERE
A PROCESS IN PLACE THE DTS HAS
TO MAKE SURE TAXPAYER DOLLARS
ARE STILL PROTECTED. THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION GROVE AND YES
WE DO HAVE PROCESSES AND
PROCEDURES- ESPECIALLY IN THESE
TIMES WE HAVE EXTREME LOADS OF
GOODS AND SERVICES AND I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT. AT THE END OF
HIGHLIGHTS SOME OF THE- THE
COUNTERMEASURES WERE PUTTING OR
SOME OF THE- ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WE ARE DEVELOPING AT
THE CHEST AND PROMOTING. TO
HELP. OUT WITH SOME OF THE
CONTRACTING THAT IS OCCURRING
UNDER EMERGENCY MEASURES SO THAT
WE CAN- HAVE A LIST OF APPROVED
VENDORS THAT WE CAN GO TO ON
SOME OF. THESE ITEMS THAT ARE
CONSTANTLY BEING PURCHASE BUT
FOR OUR STANDARDS AND PROCEDURES
THE ONES THAT ARE PROCUREMENT
DIVISION FOLLOWS. OUR VENDORS
ARE ASKED. TO PROVIDE A QUOTE
WITH PRICING AND DELIVERED THE
DELIVERY OF SCHEDULES- OF
WHATEVER GOODS OR SERVICES THEY
ARE GOING TO PROVIDE. THEY ARE
ASKED TO PROVIDE PAID DATA-
BUYERS. FROM THE EVALUATE COLD
TO THE- IN RECENT PRICING. OUR
BUYERS ALSO VALLEY P. EDE. WE
MAKE SURE THEY'RE IN GOOD- WE
ARE ABLE TO LOOK UP THE VENDORS
IN OUR FISCALE SYSTEM. AND
BUYERS FROM THE STATE NEGOTIATE
WITH VENDORS ON PRICING PAYMENT
TERMS AND DELIVERY AND DEPENDING
ON THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE
CONTRACT- AND THE SIZE OF THE
CONTRACTOR CHIEF PROCUREMENT
OFFICER WILL DISCUSS AND
COLLABORATE. WITH- THE
LEADERSHIP. AT THE UNIFIED
COORDINATION GROUP SO IF IT'S AN
EMERGENCY CONTRACT AND WE WORK
REALLY CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE. OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES ON THOSE EMERGENCY
CONTRACTS OF A REGULAR CONTRACTS
WE FOLLOW OUR REGULAR PROCEDURES
THAT ARE NOT UNDER AN EMERGENCY
CONTRACT SHALL WE CAN. YOU KNOW
. REGULAR BID- PROCESS. WELL WE
HAVE DONE TO ESTABLISH- SOME
MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO BRING IN
CONTRACTS UNDER THESE EMERGENCY
NEEDS THIS PROMOTE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE IS BY HAVING
A LIST OF APPROVED VENDORS. FOR
ITEMS AND GOODS THAT ARE IN
CONSTANT NEED ESPECIALLY DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND BECAUSE OF OUR
CONSTANT WILDFIRES AND WE HAD A
REGISTRY OF ALL THE SMALL
BUSINESS. AND DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISES POSTED ON
OCTOBER FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SO NOW DEPARTMENTS CAN GO TO
THAT LIST AND GO TO AN APPROVED.
LIST OF VENDORS THAT HAVE BEEN
VETTED- AND THAT WOULD PRECLUDE
US HAVING TO DO THE SOLE SOURCE
CONTRACTS BECAUSE THESE VENDORS
HAVE ALREADY GONE THROUGH A
CERTIFICATION PROCESS. AND OUR
BUYERS HAVE THAT IT THOSE
VENDORS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I KNOW YOU'VE ONLY
BEEN IN THIS POSITION AND NOT
YET A YEAR RIGHT. NOT YET A YEAR
ALMOST THOUGH- BUT BECAUSE YOU
CAME ON DURING THE CODED
SITUATION WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
LESSONS THAT YOU THINK THAT
YOU'VE LEARNED AND HOW YOU CAN
IMPLEMENT THOSE TO CREATE. A
BETTER QUALITY OF SERVICES THAT
PEOPLE GET FROM TGS. CERTAINLY I
THINK THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
SENATOR AND I THINK THAT- I'M
THE LIVING BREATHING EXAMPLE
HYBRID WORK- AND I HAVE TOLD
PEOPLE I AM THE DIRECTOR THAT'S
ON THE ROAD. I'M GOING TO VISIT
A LOT OF OUR SITE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND I'VE ACTUALLY HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING ALONGSIDE
SOME OF OUR FACILITIES
MANAGEMENT DIVISION TEAM
MEMBERS. UNDERSTAND WHAT A AY
IN THE LIFE OF THEIR WORK IS
LIKE. WHETHER IT'S ACTUALLY- NO
DOING SOME LANDSCAPING OF THE
CAPITOL. PARK OR- WORKING IN ONE
OF OUR BUILDINGS AND WORKING
WITH OUR BUILDING ENGINEERS TO
UNDERSTAND THE PERSPECTIVE OF
THOSE EMPLOYEES. THAT HAVE NOT
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF TELEWORK OR
HYBRID WORK- SO AS THE DIRECTOR
WHO'S ON THE CONSTANTLY ON THE
ROAD AND ON THE GO. I'M TRYING
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT IS-
WHAT OUR EMPLOYEES ARE FACING
HOW OUR CUSTOMERS ARE GETTING
THEIR SERVICES WHETHER IT'S
VIRTUAL OR IN THESE DIGITAL-
PLATFORMS OR- CUSTOMER SERVICE
STAFF. AND IT'S GIVEN ME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO TELEWORK
AS EDS IS. THE DEPARTMENT THAT'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE TELEWORK
POLICY IN COLLABORATION WITH OUR
CALIFORNIA HUMAN. RESOURCES
DEPARTMENT- I WHAT I'VE LEARNED
IS THAT FOLKS REALLY CARE TO BE
SEEN OUR- EMPLOYEES- LOVE TO BE
CALIFORNIANS. AND PTSIS REALLY
THE FRONT DOOR TO THE BUSINESS
OPERATIONS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WHEN. SOMEBODY
COMES TO YOU TO SAY HOW ARE WE
DOING IT GOES A LONG WAY. WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT- I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH AND%
THROUGH THE LAST QUESTION I HAVE
IS- AT HOW IS THE OFFICE OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION
RESPONDING TO THE RECENT BUREAU
OF STATE AUDITS REPORT FINDINGS
SUGGESTING THAT THE OFFICES.
FIRST COME FIRST. AND SERVED
PROCESS. HAS READ. IN INEQUITIES
AND IN WHICH PROJECTS ARE FUNDED
. SO I BELIEVE THERE WAS IN THE-
THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION IS CONDUCTING A
VARIETY OF WORKSHOPS TO ENSURE
THAT INFORMATION IS. REACHING
ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
PROVIDING SUPPORT- TO THE
SMALLEST OF DISTRICTS THE
LARGEST OF DISTRICTS FOR FUTURE
FUNDING AND CURRENT FUNDING
CYCLES- AND WITH THAT I WOULD
SAY THAT I HAVE FULL FAITH IN
THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION TO MAKE THEMSELVES
AVAILABLE. TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
AND- WORK WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE IN NEED. THANK YOU AM I
LOOK FORWARD TO- SUPPORTING YOUR
CONFIRMATION FROM ONE WOMAN
WHO'S THE FIRST TO ANOTHER WOMAN
WHO IS THE FIRST AND NOW
THROWING IT BACK TO. THE FIRST
FEMALE PRO TEM OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATIVE
SENATE- FOR THE SENATE SO. AS
I'M SURE SHE'S GONNA ENJOY
SUPPORTING YOU AS WELL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU- SENATOR
GROVE AND AUG I APPRECIATE ALL
THE COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS HI. I
JUST WANTED TO ASK IN TERMS OF
THE ISSUE OF THE GERMAN AND I'M
MORE INTERESTED IN. OF
PROCUREMENT AS IT RELATES TO HOW
YOU ARE ABLE TO DIVERSIFY AND
APPRECIATING WHAT SENATOR BROKE
JUST SAID ABOUT THE FIRST WOMAN
FIRST ENOUGH. YOU KNOW MY SPOUSE
IS A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER- AND
HAS A NUMBER OF THOSE
DISTINCTIONS. NOT DISABLED
VETERANS- WHICH IS EQUALLY
IMPORTANT TO OTHER MINORITY
OWNED. OR SMALL BUSINESSES AND.
YOU KNOW WHAT I FIND- IS THAT.
AND REALLY DIVERSITY AND
DIVERSIFYING IT FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES ACROSS THE SPECTRUM.
IS HAS TO BE INTENTIONAL IT IS
IT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT JUST
HAPPENS THAT WHEN YOU MARRY THAT
WITH THE CONCEPT OF GOVERNMENT.
YOU KNOW AND- FORGIVE ME
SEEMINGLY BUREAUCRACY THAT HAS
TO. HAS TO EXIST FOR MANY
REASONS ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY OF PROCESS A FAIR
PROCESS. HOW DO YOU BALANCE ALL
OF THOSE THINGS I'M SURE YOU
APPROACH THIS JOB FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE OF THE FIRST BUT-
SECUREMENT WILL MAKE PEOPLE'S
EYES GLAZE OVER AND I KNOW THAT
THAT MY COLLEAGUES ASK QUESTIONS
ABOUT- YOU KNOW PROCUREMENT
DURING THE PANDEMIC IN EMERGENCY
AND NON. COMPETE BUT JUST
GENERALLY A PROCUREMENT A NUMBER
OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THEIR FRUSTRATION. ABOUT
THE LACK OF- OUR OUT REACH AND
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
HAVING THOSE LISTS. OF PRE
VETTED YOU KNOW JUST GIVE ME
YOUR EXPERIENCE AND WHAT YOU SEE
AND THEN THE RESPONSES FROM
BUSINESSES WHO MAY REACH OUT AND
SAY WE DON'T REALLY HAVE ACCESS
TO THE STATE PROCUREMENT PROCESS
I'M JUST CURIOUS. YOUR BROUGHT
US THOUGHTS ON THAT AND HOW YOU
INTEND TO. TRY TO HELP THAT
ALONG. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
DIMENSIONS FOR THAT QUESTION- IF
YOU RECALL FROM MY OPENING
STATEMENT THAT MY PARENTS HAD A
SMALL BUSINESS AND WE'RE NEVER
ABLE TO GET A GOVERNMENT
CONTRACT IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT
FOR THEM TO EVEN NAVIGATE. IN
OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM LET ALONE HOW
TO BET ON SOMETHING THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN A PRETTY EASY- PROCESS
HAD THEY HAD MORE ACCESS AND
INFORMATION THAT WAS READILY
AVAILABLE IN A LANGUAGE THEY CAN
UNDERSTAND- WITH WORKSHOPS
SECOND WALK THEM THROUGH HOW TO
DO THAT. RIGHT SO WHEN IT CAME
TO D. J. S. HAVING BEEN A CLIENT
FOR SO LONG AND- UNDERSTANDING
THE PRIVILEGE OF LEADING. THE
BUSINESS BACK HOME PHONE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BEING THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY. AND
KNOWING THAT IN CALIFORNIA ARE
SMALL BUSINESSES. REALLY ARE THE
LIFELINE TO OUR ECONOMIC
VITALITY AND RECOVERY I MET WITH
MY ENTIRE TEAM AND I SAID. I'M
GOING TO REALLY FOCUS ON THREE
ELEMENTS AT EACH YES
SUSTAINABILITY. LEVERAGING A
REAL ESTATE TO- REACH MORE
CLIMATE RESILIENCY AND CREATING
EFFICIENCIES IN PROCUREMENT AND
I SPOKE AND SAT DOWN WITH. OUR
PROCUREMENT DIVISION DEPUTY
DIRECTOR SHE'S ALSO OUR CHIEF
PROCUREMENT OFFICER FOR THE
STATE AND IS THAT HOW CAN WE
MOVE THAT NEEDLE OF BEING MORE
EFFICIENT. MORE TRANSPARENT AND
MORE HUMAN CENTRIC MEANING WE
REALLY UNDERSTAND. HOW ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES YOU KNOW WHEN THEY
LOOK AT AN ART PIECE- THEY
WALKING THROUGH THAT DOOR IT'S
DAUNTING TO- EITHER GO THROUGH A
CERTIFICATION OR RESPOND TO AN
RFP. WHAT ARE WE DOING TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S THAT TRANSPARENCY
AND INFORMATION THAT THE
CLASSICAL SO- SOME OF THE WORK
WAS ALREADY BEING DONE AND I'M
GLAD SHE AND I SAW I TO II. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN
PROMOTING IS EIGHT TASK ORIENTED
MEMO. OF THE VARIOUS ITEMS WE
WANT TO DO TO MOVE THE. NEEDLE
ON SMALL BUSINESS- AND SMALL
BUSINESS PARTISAN. ONE THIS IS
AN BRIDGE STREET FOR BUSINESSES
THAT CAN PROVIDE SERVICES DURING
EMERGENCIES THAT OPEN ON OCTOBER
FIFTH- THE OTHER IS MOVING
FORWARD WITH A VARIOUS ADVISORY
COUNCILS AND REALLY LEANING ON
SOME OF OUR LOCAL CHAMBERS AND
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
COUNCILS TO HELP US SHARE AND
DISSEMINATE THE INFORMATION THE
OTHER IS WORKING WITH OTHER VERY
LARGE CITIES THAT HAVE STRONG
CHAMBERS AND THAT ALSO NAVIGATE-
THE SMALL BUSINESS PROCUREMENT
PROCESS. FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
ENSURING THAT WE CAN HAVE CROSS
REGISTRIES FOR THOSE BUSINESSES
OF YOUR BUSINESS IN ORANGE
COUNTY WHEN THE INLAND EMPIRE IN
YOUR REGISTERED IN THOSE
COUNTIES THAT THERE WOULD BE A
CROSS REGISTRATION ACROSS A
RECIPROCITY WITH THE STATE AND
THAT THROUGH OUR SYSTEM KELLY
PROCURE OR THEIR SYSTEMS THEY
WOULD HAVE ACCESS. TO THE
INFORMATION OF THE SAME.
CONTRACTS THAT ARE BEING. SO WE
ARE WORKING TO MOVE THAT NEEDLE
I AM- I'M REALLY INTENT ON
MOVING THIS FORWARD AND THEY
PARTICIPATE A LOT IN THESE
MEETINGS- WHICH IS NOT. ALWAYS
YOU KNOW THE ROLE OF A DIRECTOR
BUT IT BECAUSE I'M SO COMMITTED.
TO SEEING THOSE DOORS OPEN AND
OPEN MORE WIDELY FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES. I APPRECIATE THAT
LET ME ASK YOU ANOTHER QUESTION
REAL ALONG THOSE LINES. WHEN
THERE IS SECUREMENT AND
CONTRACTS AND SAY. MAYBE LARGER
BUSINESSES GET THE AWARDS GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND THEY
HAVE- SUBCONTRACTORS. YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES WHAT I'VE HEARD AT
LEAST FROM SMALL BUSINESSES I
KNOW THAT THEY GET SELECTED TO
BE SUBS BECAUSE IT INCREASES
THEIR DIVERSITY NUMBERS AND THEN
THEY NEVER GET THE WORK OR THEY
DON'T GET TO DO THE- SO YOU KNOW
IT CAN BE FRUSTRATING WHEN A
SMALL BUSINESS. PARTNERS WITH A
LARGER. BUSINESS AND THE BENEFIT
TO THE LARGER BUSINESS OBVIOUSLY
IS THE DIVERSITY FACTOR AND YET
DID THEY DON'T GET THE WORK.
DONE HAVE YOU HEARD COMPLAINTS
OF THAT NATURE IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN LOOK AT. I HAVE NOT
HEARD THAT SPECIFIC COMPLAINT
BUT I AM HAPPY TO INFORM THAT
THAT THE COMMITTEE THAT OUR
PROCUREMENT DIVISION DOES HAVE A
TRACKING MECHANISM ESPECIALLY
UPON PAIN. THE PRIME CONTRACTOR.
ESPECIALLY IF THEY SAT OR THAT
THEY HAD A DVD OR A SMALL
BUSINESSES PART OF THIRTEEN. TO
ENSURE THAT THE SMALL BUSINESS
OR THE DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE IS GETTING PAID AND
PAID PROMPTLY AND THAT WERE SEEN
THEM ALONG THE COURSE OF THE
CONTRACT- SO THAT THIS DOESN'T
HAPPEN- I'VE- MADE. MY PREVIOUS
POSITION I HEARD ABOUT IT
ANECDOTALLY US SINCE COMING TO
DIGEST I HAVE NOT BECAUSE NOW I
KNOW THAT WE DO ACTUALLY TRACK
IT IN OUR SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATES. WHO ARE MINDING THOSE
CONTRACTS ARE HELPING
DEPARTMENTS MANAGE THOSE
CONTRACTS REQUIRE THAT
INFORMATION TO ENSURE WE'RE
COUNTY- THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCACY AND THE SMALL THE
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE NUMBERS. THAT WE ARE
REPORT NOT. THANK YOU. WELL I.
THAT YOU COME WITH THE VALUE SET
THAT YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS THAT YOU ALSO
REMINDED ME OF IN YOUR RESPONSE
TO MY FIRST QUESTION AROUND
PROCUREMENT- I THINK THAT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE IF
EVER WE'RE GOING TO. DRILL DOWN
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A FOCUS AND
INTENTION AND YOU COME WITH
THAT- PERSPECTIVES AND SO I
APPRECIATE. THAT AND I WISH YOU
THE BEST OF LUCK. THANK YOU IN
THIS REGARD- SENATOR COM LONGER
IS HERE- I THINK YOU MIGHT HAVE
HEARD ME SAY I HAD TO MEMBERS
WHO HAD TO LEAVE AND GO TO
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE SO. HE HAS
REURNED AND I KNOW THIS IS AN
ISSUE OF IMPORTANCE TO HER
SOMETHING TO TURN IT OVER TO
SENATOR PROBLEM LONGER. EIGHTY
MADAM FOR TEN AM IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU AGAIN MISS LAST SO- LAST
LAST I SAW YOU WE ACTUALLY WERE
BOTH AT EXPOSITION PARK- SAVING
THE DAY THERE. SO I KNOW- SOME
OF MY COLLEAGUES ASKED ABOUT-
BUILDINGS. AND SORT OF BUILDING
SURPLUS SAYS THAT THE STATE- IS
MANAGING. SO I JUST HAVE A
QUESTION FOLLOWING UP ON- ON
THAT MOST PEOPLE KNOW THAT I
HAVE THIS EVD BUILDING ON FIFTY
FOURTH AND CURRENT JOB BUT THERE
ARE SOME OTHER BUILDINGS THAT
ARE ALSO- THE STATE OWNED IN THE
DISTRICT- THAT ARE HAVE BEEN
DAYS MENTIONED OR THEY'RE NOT
BEING UTILIZED X. CETERA. ONE OF
THEM I THINK ON BROADWAY AND
MAYBE FOURTEENTH IS- LOOKING AT
BEING TURNED INTO HOUSING SO I'D
JUST LIKE TO ASK YOU IF YOU CAN
KIND OF SHARE. THE ABOUT YOUR
THOUGHTS ON. YOU KNOW STATE
PRESENCE. VIS A VIS FACILITIES-
AND ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
WHAT THAT MEANS TO YOU I
RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE A HUGE
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
CHALLENGES. AND- LOS ANGELES.
AND YET. YOU KNOW HAVING A STATE
OWNED THE BUILDING. TURNED INTO
HOUSING- COULD INFER TO PEOPLE
THAT THE STATE IS NOT PRESENT-
IN THAT PARTICULAR PART OF TOWN
AND SO IF THOSE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING YOU KNOW. WHAT'S THE
ROLE WHAT ROLE IN MAINTAINING A
PRESENCE IN THE COMMUNITY SO IF
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE LOOKING TO
CHANGE IT INTO HOUSING HOUSE THE
COMMUNITY INVOLVED AND ENGAGED
AND THE DISCUSSIONS AROUND IF
THEY EVEN WANT IT AND WHAT THAT
WOULD LOOK LIKE- AND IF THERE
ARE IDEAS TO SORT OF RE OPEN
FACILITIES BACK UP TO THEIR
ORIGINAL INTENDED PURPOSE YOU
KNOW HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN
BECAUSE- ULTIMATELY I THINK.
CONSTITUENTS WANT TO SEE US. AND
OFTENTIMES OF FACILITY. RIGHT
WITH EMPLOYEES IN THERE HELPING
YOU. IS THE BEST WAY TO VISUALLY
EXERCISE YOUR PRESENT. SO GIVEN
THE FACT THAT YOU WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL OF THE
FACILITIES AND ULTIMATELY AN
AMBASSADOR. TO THE STATE'S
PRESENCE IN OUR DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA JUST WANT TO KNOW
YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW WE SORT OF
MAINTAIN THAT. CENTER CALENDAR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
QUESTION I REALLY APPRECIATE IT
BECAUSE LIKE YOU I TRULY BELIEVE
THAT HAVING A PROPER BALANCE AND
SPREAD. OF BOTH SERVICES AND
AMENITIES IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
THOSE THAT. NEED ACCESS TO. BOTH
THE SERVICES THE GOVERNMENT
PROVIDES BUT ALSO TO THE
AMENITIES LIKE PARKS AND HOUSING
THAT ARE SO NEEDED. AND SO- TWO
PARTS TO THIS ANSWER ON A ONE
AND THE PROPERTY ON FIFTEENTH
AND BROADWAY. ARE SLATED SURPLUS
AND- IT WAS PUT OUT TO BID FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF- DDS PROVIDES SUPPORT
IN TRANSACTIONAL ARM TO THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING EFFORTS THAT-
BE HOUSING COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT IS MOVING FORWARD AND
IN THAT PARTICULAR PROPERTY HAS
BEEN AWARDED SO I'M HAPPY TO
REPORT SINCE THE LAST TIME WE
SPOKE ABOUT THIS IT'S BEEN
AWARDED. AMENDED THE DEVELOPER
WILL BE CARRYING THE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS TO SHARE WITH
THE COMMUNITY DESIGN PLANS- MANY
PLANS FOR THAT PARTICULAR SITE
AND FIFTEEN THEN BROADWAY IS
DEFINITELY AN AREA THAT NEEDS A
LOT OF HOUSING NOW BALANCING
THAT WITH OF THE VERY IMPORTANT
STATEMENT THAT YOU MADE WISHES
SERVICES IN ACCESS TO GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES AND SEEN US ADVOCATE
FOR THE COMMUNITY THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING THOSE. SERVICES FOR.
GOING TO THE PROP ON SHOP. DGS
THE STEADFAST AND SUPPORTIVE OF
EATING AND STAND TO PART WITH
THEM TO- HELP RECOVER THAT
PROPERTY THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
DEVELOPMENT AS OF TODAY AND I'M
VERY HAPPY TO REPORT TO YOU- ON
INTO FOR THE DGS IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR RECOVERING THAT PROPERTY AND
ENSURING THAT THE PROPERTY OWNER
SHE AND HER TEAM OF LAWYERS.
WILL FILL THEIR OBLIGATION TO
RETURN THE PROPERTY TO THE STATE
WE WERE NOTIFIED THIS AFTERNOON
THAT THE TITLE COMPANY RECEIVED
SOME DOCUMENTS FROM THE FLOOR
FORMER OWNER TODAY AND SO WE
WILL BE REVIEWING THAT FOR THE
COMPLETENESS AND THEN WORKING
WITH EDT ON NEXT STEPS AND
KEEPING YOUR OFFICE SURPRISED.
SO I THINK THE WAY WE LOOK AT
THIS- MOVING FORWARD IS ENSURING
THERE'S A PROPER SPREAD ON
ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES WHERE
THERE'S- YOU KNOW SO THERE'S
DEPRESSED OR AND IF THEY'RE IF
THEY HAVE ECONOMIC- NEED. THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO WALK TO
SOME OF THESE RESOURCES OR- TAKE
A SHORT BUS RIDE OR A SHORT
DRIVE TO SOME OF THESE OFFICES
AND IS VERY IMPORTANT AND AS WE
LOOK AT OUR SURPLUS PROPERTIES
AND THE INVENTORY THAT WAS
SUBMITTED TO DO JUST FOR YOU I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR MY
TEAM. TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENTS TO ENSURE THAT WE.
ARE NOT LEAVING ANY GAPS. OF
SERVICES AREA AND WHERE WE ARE
TO FOR THAT TO THE ATTENTION OF
THE LET. AND JUST ASK YOU ALL
WHO REPRESENT THESE GREAT
COMMUNITIES. THIS IS WHAT WAS
THE MADE IN TERMS OF SURPLUS.
THESE ARE THE OTHER LOCATIONS
OF- GOVERNMENT SERVICES IN YOUR
COMMUNITY. CAN YOU HELP US
ENSURE THAT WE ARE NOT MISSING
ANY NOOK AND CRANNY IN YOUR
COMMUNITY SO NO ONE GOES UNDER
REPRESENTED. WELL THANK YOU FOR
THAT RESPONSE AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT BIT OF CAUTIONARY
OPTIMISTIC NEWS I'M SURE ANY
CONSTITUENTS LISTENING WILL BE-
POPPING FROM BOTTLES. SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO THE
STATE. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME CENTER THE OTHER DAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR COM AUGER AND-
THANK YOU FOR DOING DOUBLE DUTY
. REALLY APPRECIATE IT. I THINK
NOW I IF NO FURTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS I THINK I COVERED ARE
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. AND LET ME E. C. I. C.
NO ONE STEPPING FORWARD IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. SO I'M
GOING TO- WELCOME BACK OUR
MODERATOR TO QUEUE UP THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT WITH A
REMINDER. TO THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION IF ANY THAT YOU
REPRESENT AND YOUR POSITION- ON
THE APPOINTMENT AND PLEASE AGAIN
SPEAK SLOWLY SO THAT OUR COURT
REPORTER WILL BE ABLE TO GET
YOUR COMMENTS. AND WITH THAT
WELCOME BACK OF MADAME MODERATOR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT PRESS THE
ONE THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN FOR
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOR JUST SO
COULDN'T- CONFUSED WHAT HAPPENED
TO THE WINNER AND PAN. MA'AM I
HAVE MADE TWO COMMENTS ON THIS
THAT IS AN INTERNAL FUNCTION
THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN DISPENSED
WITH IT WAS A THREE TO VOTE
THOSE BILLS HAVE REFERRED BEEN
REFERRED TO. COMMITTEES THE
COMMITTEES WILL NOTICE OF WHEN
THOSE BILLS ARE SET TO BE
SCHEDULED WE START IN MARCH. ALL
RIGHT NOW WE JUST HAVE BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE HEARINGS AND SO
PLEASE BE SURE TO LOOK AT THE
WEBSITE TO SEE WHEN THOSE BILLS
HAVE BEEN SCHEDULED TO BE HEARD
BEFORE VARIOUS COMMITTEES. THAT
WAS A THREE TWO VOTE AND SO WE
HAVE DISPENSED WITH THAT AND IT
IS NOT A DEBATABLE ITEM IT'S AN
INTERNAL FUNCTION OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE. SO WITH THAT I
APPRECIATE YOUR DILIGENCE AND
YOUR- YOU'RE CALLING IN MADAME
MODERATOR I NEED TO MOVE TO THE
NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU. YEAH AND
MAXIMO TO THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HELLO SHARE ENGINE MEMBERS CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN'T. GREAT
WONDERFUL THANK YOU I AM CALLING
BECAUSE I AM OPPOSED SB EIGHT
SEVEN ONE AND ENTER MA'AM I'M
GONNA UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO RULE
YOU OUT OF ORDER THAT IS NOT AN
ITEM OF DISCUSSION BEFORE THE
RULES COMMITTEE. SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR CALLING IN BUT- MADAME
MODERATOR WE NEED TO GO TO THE
NEXT WITNESS. METSOVO TO LINE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M HELEN TAURUS
DEAL OF HIS FINAL ORGANIZED TO
POLITICALLY QUALITY BETTER KNOWN
AS POPE AND IT'S A CORD AT
DIRECTOR LOTS OF CONFIRMATION
FOR DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES.
I MET THE DIRECTOR IN JANUARY OF
TWO THOUSAND FOUR WHEN SHE WAS
SELECTED AS A PARTICIPANT IN THE
HOPES LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE.
THROUGH THAT EXPERIENCE AND
BEING A LOCAL LEADER IN LOS
ANGELES AREA I HAVE WITNESSED
THE DIRECTOR BEING A UNIFIED
FORCE BETWEEN COMMUNITY AND
GOVERNMENT A SERVANT LEADER
ALWAYS LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
IMPROVE GOVERNANCE PROCESSES TO
BE INCLUSIVE COMMUNITY SHE GIVES
OF HER TIME TO MENTOR OTHERS
THOUGH THAT WHILE SHE MAY BE THE
FIRST LATINA IN A KEY POSITION
SHE WILL NOT BE A LOT. I'VE ALSO
BEEN IN ALL OF THE DIRECTOR
LOSSES INTELLECT AND EXPERTISE
IN A VARIETY OF FIELDS RANGING
FROM REAL ESTATE TO NEGOTIATE
HISTORICAL DEALS THAT BRING
PRIDE IMPORTANT JOBS OUR
COMMUNITY IN MY OPINION DIRECTOR
LAST RELEASED NOT ONLY QUALIFIED
TO BE THE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT GEL SERVICES. SHE
WILL CONTINUE TO LEAD THE
DEPARTMENT WITH INTEGRITY AND
TRANSPARENCY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU OUR.
NEXT WITNESS MADAME MODERATOR.
MAXIMALS LINE TO PLEASE GO OUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BETTY
CHANCE- OF CORP STRATEGY FOR THE
ANGELES FOOTBALL CLUB. AND THEN
WRAP IT PUBLICLY WE ACTUALLY
HAVE TO YOUR PLAN AND THAT'S
WHAT- AND- HOPE NO THE SEASON
WEEK BUT- YOU RELEASED YOU- THAT
TO LOS WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF OUR
COMPANY. I HAVE HAD THIS TO WORK
WITH- DOCTOR LAW THE FOR OVERSEE
AND A HALF YEARS AT A AT A BEGAN
WITH- THE ONE GLOBE CLUB LOOK
FOR AS- AND- AN OF OUR THE STATE
BY THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
EVEN. INSTRUMENTAL IN WORKING
WITH PARK AND IF THE AND IN MANY
. INCLUDING S. T. V. GM AT THE
KEY THAN OTHERS HOW TO REALLY A
FINAL. AND GET OUR- SECURE THE
FIVE AND SO- SHE'D BEEN ABLE TO-
OPEN I'M CAME BACK ATM. AT
COMMITTEE- I EXPO PARK. SHE WAS
ISSUE HELPFUL TO US IN AND
MAKING SURE THAT I'M EVERYONE OF
THEM SAME PAGE. FOR TRANSFER.
AND THAT SHE THE BEST OUT FOR
ALL PARTIES AT THE PARK AND FOR
HOW ORGANIZATION. AND DISBANDED
COULD NOT ALLOW OF DURING THE
TIME SHE WAS THERE AT- SHE WAS
OVERSAW THE UFC ONE OF CON
CALLED. THE LIEUTENANT OF
PROJECT THAT BIG BUILT NOW- AND
OTHERS IN- A OVER- TO DOLLARS
WORTH OF AND I WILL TALK ABOUT.
AND THE- ENORMOUS AT THE AND
SOCIAL POSITIVE THAT HAD. IN THE
KING. AND THE CITY- AFTER
COMPLETE THIS WENT TO THE STATE
OPERATING A STATE. WHICH WATCHED
WHAT LARGER. AND EVEN THAT THAT
TIME THE LOS ANGELES OFF BUY A
CAR HIM WITH HER LEADER. AND
WITH THE MOBILE SHOULD ABLE.
SUCCESSFULLY YOU KNOW THAT THAT
. WOULD DELIVER ALL THE- AND
ALSO ENSURE THAT THE PART I
WOULD FUNCTIONS WHILE I WOULD
BUT THE COMPLEX NAY. OF THE
DEATH ENTITIES IN OFF OF THE
DIFFERENT AUDIENCES AND THE
PUBLIC THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE
PART AS WELL- AND ALL KNOW THAT
SOME COMMON. AT THE OF THAT
PARKS MASTER PLAN. WITH THE MANY
STAKEHOLDER AT HAND INCLUDING
ALL PORT HE AND LOOKING. WHAT
ABOUT THE- SHE WAS ABLE TO.
COORDINATE AND REAL TO GO.
MAGICAL TO REALLY GET A- THAT
DID EXIST BACKING. THE MAP THE
FUTURE. OF THE PARKING ENTITY TO
REALLY HOW BECOME A CO LED FOR
CITY AND NATIONAL PARKS. I WOULD
THAT WE- SUPPORT. A DOOR TO A
LOT L. AS WE CAN FOR.
LEGISLATORS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR MUCH OF THAT TEST
- MAN I'M- OF MODERATOR NEXT
WITH. NEXT TO LINE AND NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TIME DAVID
CHRISTENSEN I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE TO HAVE THAT WHAT ABOUT
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AS I
THURSDAY A MEMBER INTO. OF THE
LOS UNITS SCHOOL DISTRICT BOND
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE I'VE STAYED
IN TOUCH AND FOLLOWED HER CAREER
EVER SINCE THEN. I'VE FOUND HER
TO BE A STRONG QUIET FOR THAT
COMBINES THEIR INTELLECTUAL
GIFTS WITH THE ABILITY TO
PRODUCE RESULTS. SO I STILL HAS
ADVANCED IN VERY BACKGROUND FROM
REAL ESTATE DEVELOPMENTS TO
MAJOR PARK MANAGEMENT. THESE
SKILLS WERE HOME WHEN SHE WAS
THE JOINT YOUTH MANAGER FOR THE
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR BOND
CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM FOR THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THIS PROGRAM DEMONSTRATED HER
ABILITY TO FORM AND FOSTER
PARTNERSHIPS. WELL IF YOU COULD
BE. AND MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR
ABILITY TO DELIVER. THESE
BY HER WORK AS GENERAL MANAGER
OF EXPOSITION PARK NOT ONLY DID
SHE AMPLY MANAGING PARK WITH A
DIVERSE CLIENT BASE. BUT HELPED
LEAD OVER ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
CONSTRUCTION YOUR INNER SEVEN
YEAR TENURE. FAISAL'S WIDE
RANGING PROFESSIONAL BACKGROUND
AND COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC SERVICE
UNIQUELY QUALIFIES HER TO BE
CONFIRMED AS DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA'S DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAME
MODERATOR MORE WITNESSES. YES
THEY HAVE ABOUT THREE MORE IN
THE QUEUE WILL MOVE TO LINE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT APPROACH HAD
MANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS BATTLING
COOPER FROM YELP AND MARK ROAD
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
OF ENGINEERING COMPANIES
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE PLEASED TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
CONFIRMATION MEDLOCK'S OUT. HIS
SERVE AS THE DIRECTOR OF EACH
YEAH WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH HER IN THIS CAPACITY HE
HE'LL THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. MAXIM OF LINE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TO THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MICHELLE
HÌNH I'M A SENIOR MANAGER WITH
DIALOGUE OF PROPERTIES IN THE
CHARGE OF BUILDING THE LUCAS
MUSEUM OF NARRATIVE PARK-
NARRATIVE ARC. IN EXPO PARK I'VE
KNOWN ANA MYSELF FOR FIVE YEARS
NOW AND WE CAME TOGETHER BECAUSE
OF THIS PROJECT SHE WAS- VERY
SUPPORTIVE. IN BRINGING US TO
THE PARK WE HAVE MANY OPTIONS
DEFENDER IN THE STATE BUT CHOSE
THIS LOCATION BECAUSE OF THE
PARTNERING THAT WAS PROMISED BY
THE CITY AND THE STATE- IT
PROVED TO BE A VERY BENEFICIAL
ON THAT WAS TRUE TO HER WORD SHE
WAS AN EXCELLENT PARTNER.
COMMUNICATOR COLLABORATOR AND
MEDIATOR- AS FR AS YOUR
PROFESSIONAL LIVES AND- BAR NINE
HE'S HANDS DOWN ONE OF THE BEST.
I WOULD SAY- THERE WERE NO
HICCUPS I WOULD. ALSO. LIKE TO-
ALMOST PICKING ON SOME THE
THINGS THAT DANNY SAID LA F.
FOOTBALL- THE AMOUNT
CONSTRUCTION THAT WAS GOING ON
AT THAT TIME MAJOR CONSTRUCTION
NOT ONLY DID WE COME INTO THE
PARK TO BREAK GROUND. AND WE'RE
STILL UNDER CONSTRUCTION BUT SHE
HAD THE FOOTBALL CLUB LAFC
BUILDING THEIR COLISEUM YOU HAVE
A COPY. ADM I'M SORRY YOU HAD TO
BE POLICY DOING A MAJOR AND IF.
AND ON TOP OF THAT WITH THE DAY
TO DAY THINGS YOU HAVE U. S.
FOOTBALL AND NFL GAMES GOING ON
AND IN THE MIDST OF THAT WE HAD
NO HICCUPS WITH CONSTRUCTION AND
THAT WAS LARGELY BECAUSE- THE
COMMUNICATION THE TRANSPARENCY
THAT SHE PROVIDED- SHE WAS VERY
COMMUNICATIVE. EVERYONE ARE YOU
GOING TO FIND TRACKS YOU CAN
EXPLAIN THINGS SO THAT THEIR
WORK MISUNDERSTANDING OR
MISCOMMUNICATION AMONG THE
DIFFERENT PARTNERS IN THE PARK.
AND SO FOR THAT- WE HIGHLY
SUPPORT. ON IT IN THIS POSITION
AND HOPE THAT SHE IS DEFINITELY
CONFIRMED. AS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE T. S. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY-
MATAMATA. RAIDER NEXT WITNESS.
YES TO THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THAT MAY YES YESTERDAY
GO AHEAD. REMEMBER I'M
ADVOCATING FOR THOUSANDS OF
PARENTS WHO STRONGLY OPPOSES
THIS PROJECT AND ALSO SB THIRTY
ONE AND- THANK YOU I MET A
MODERATOR OTHER WITNESSES. AT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN
THE QUEUE THANK YOU ARE WE WILL
COME BACK INTO A ROOM I HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WILL COME BACK INTO ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. I AND I CAN I
SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE WHO ARE HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SEMANA MODERATOR I'M
GONNA COME RIGHT BACK TO YOU TO
GO AHEAD AND QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS. APPOINTMENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO OPPOSE. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. AND AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR- I
KNOW WE'LL BE BACK WITH YOU IN A
LITTLE WHILE FOR THE LAST
APPOINTMENT I JUST WANT TO THANK
ALL OF THEM. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO HAVE STAYED TRUE TO
THIS MEETING ALL THE WAY THROUGH
THIS FAR AND- PAID SUCH
ATTENTION THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO
COMMENT ON OTHERS SPEAKERS- TODD
TESTIMONY AS WELL AS TO THE
SENATORS- THAT'S A TESTAMENT I
THINK- MISSILE ALSO TO YOUR-
CONFIRMATION AND THAT PEOPLE
WERE WILLING TO. SHARE WHAT THEY
DID WITH US ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCE WITH YOU SO. I'M
IMPRESSED WITH MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO HAVE HUNG IN HERE TO.
TO GIVE YOU SUPPORT. ARM WITH
THAT I AM HAPPY TO TURN TO
SENATOR LAYERED TO MAKE A MOTION
I WOULD MOVE THE CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GROVE I GROW I
KAMLAGER LAYER HI THERE I BATES
AYE BATES AYE ATKINS HI ATKINS
AYE ON CALL THIS WILL BE ON CALL
I TO ALLOW SENATOR COM LONGER TO
COME BACK AND CAST HER VOTE AS
WELL BUT YOU HAVE FOUR VOTES HI
AND A LIKELY ALL LIKELY KNOWS
THAT THIS WILL MOVE FORWARD TO
THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONFIRMATION SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TOM AND CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU TO. ALL OF YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION ABSOLUTELY. LET ME
JUST CHECK AND SEE IF WE NEED TO
TAKE ANOTHER BREAK. NO OKAY- I
LOVE HOW WE CAN COMMUNICATE AND-
YOU TAKE A BREAK OR MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU SO MUCH HAINA- OKAY SO
WE ARE GOING TO GO TO ITEM ONE
C. AND APPOINTEE WHO'S ALREADY
BEEN MADE REFERENCE TO BUY. BY
THE PREVIOUS APPOINTEE AND LET
ME WELCOME IDA CLAIRE WHO IS
BEING APPOINTED OR HAS BEEN
APPOINTED AS OUR STATE-
ARCHITECT. AND I'M GOING TO
INVITE YOU MISS CLEAR TO DO THE
SAME THING WHICH IS INTRODUCE
YOURSELF RECOGNIZE ANYONE YOU
WOULD LIKE TO THAT. SUPPORTS YOU
AND THAT YOU WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
DO ANY OPENING COMMENTS AND THEN
WE'LL GO RIGHT TO OUR- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THEIR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS SO WELCOME. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS AND PRO
TEM ACTIONS I AM HONORED AND
EAGER TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY
THIS CONFIRMATION HEARING. I AM
JOINED HERE TODAY BY MY HUSBAND
JEFF MY ADULT CHILDREN JOSEPH
SERRA AND ELIANA AND MY MOTHER
ADRIANA. MY FAMILY IS A GREAT
SOURCE OF PRIDE FOR ME AND HAVE
SUPPORTED ME IN SEEKING THIS
APPOINTMENT. I WANT TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR MY
APPOINTMENT IN THIS COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR REVIEW OF MY
QUALIFICATIONS. I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE TIME YOUR STAFF
HAS TAKEN WITH ME AND I'M VERY
THANKFUL FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
MY PASSION FOR ARCHITECTURE
BEGAN AS A CHILD WHEN AS THE
DAUGHTER OF ITALIAN IMMIGRANTS I
WOULD TRAVEL TO ITALY TO SPEND
TIME WITH FAMILY AND WE'RE
EXPERIENCE THE POWER OF
ARCHITECTURE. LEWIN'S AND
INSPIRE GREATNESS. I BROUGHT
THIS PERSPECTIVE TO MY WORK AS
AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING SPECIALIST
USING ARCHITECTURE TO PROVIDE
EQUITY THROUGH HOUSING THAT IS
WELL DESIGNED ACCESSIBLE AND
SUSTAINABLE. I BRING THIS
IMPERATIVE TO MY WORK AT THE
DIVISION OF THE STATE ARCHITECT
PROVIDING EQUITY TO PUBLIC
SCHOOL CHILDREN THROUGH SAFE
ACCESSIBLE AND SUSTAINABLE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. MY PRIORITY
STATE ARCHITECT IS THE TIMELY
DELIVERY PLAN WRITTEN APPROVAL
AND CERTIFICATION AND INCREASING
THE SUSTAINABILITY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS WITH ECH FACILITY
IMPROVEMENT. I RECOGNIZE THAT
THE STATE ARCHITECT HAS A VOICE
IN MAKING CHANGE AND AS THE
FIRST FEMALE STATE ARCHITECT. I
WILL BE MINDFUL THAT I'M A WOMAN
IN A LEADERSHIP ROLE WE CAN
INSPIRE GIRLS THE LEADERS OF
CHANGE FOR CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE.
I'M HONORED TO SERVE THE NEW
SOME ADMINISTRATION IN THIS
CAPACITY ALONGSIDE DIRECTOR
LHASA. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
YOU COME FROM MY- THANK YOU.
WELL THANK YOU MISS CLAIRE THIS
IS QUITE A DAY FOR FIRST AND THE
AND FOR WOMEN I MIGHT ADD. AND
THEN WITH THAT I'M NOT GONNA LET
SENATOR LET GO FIRST ON. I'M
GONNA ASK VICE CHAIR. SENATOR
BATES TO KICK US OFF WITH THAT
WITH GREAT RESPECT TO THE ONE
DOLLAR BILL IS THE ONE GENTLEMAN
WITH. SENATOR GO AHEAD THANK YOU
ALL MISS CLEAR- CAN. ON ALL.
YOUR ROLL OUT OF OUR STATE
ARCHITECT I COME FROM AN
ARCHITECT FAMILY IN FACT MY
HUSBAND GRADUATED FROM THE- USC
SCHOOL OF ARCHITECTURE. MAYBE A
DECADE AND A HALF BEFORE YOU
STILL OUT THERE DOING DOING A
LITTLE WORK. BETTER I REALLY
DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON
PROCESS FIND I ACTUALLY KNOW IT
PRETTY WELL WHILE BEING A
PARTNER. OF SORTS FOR YOU KNOW
THE BETTER HALF MAYBE OF THE
ARCHITECT IN MY FAMILY THAT I
WAS INTERESTED IN- YOUR COMMENTS
ABOUT LOSING SOFT SKILLS ARE
THEY PEOPLE SKILLS AND I'M- KIND
OF WONDERING IF THEY'RE OUT TO
BECAUSE- MOST OF OUR
COMMUNICATION. WITH PEOPLE
QUESTIONS- ON PROCESS OR
PROBLEMS IF- NOT PEOPLE THE
PEOPLE ARE FACE TO FACE COULD
YOU KIND OF ELABORATE ON THAT I
THINK IT MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT
FLOW OF. AB ACROSS MANY OF OUR
AGENCIES WHERE PEOPLE ARE HAVING
TO SPEAK ON TO VOICE MAILS OR-
YOU KNOW ZOOMING ZOOMING OVER
BETTER THAN TELECONFERENCING
BUT- ANYWAY- YOUR THOUGHTS. SURE
ABSOLUTELY- THANK YOU FOR THE
CALL- I WILL SAY THE- WHILE WE
HAVE- YOU KNOW EXCEEDED OUR
EXPECTATIONS IN PERFORMING OUR
WORK WE'VE BEEN VERY TIMELY WE
WERE ABLE TO TRANSITION
SEAMLESSLY THROUGH TELEWORK-
WHAT I NEED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE SOFT SKILLS THAT OUR
PROFESSION IS VERY- WELL OUR
DEPARTMENT IS VERY CUSTOMER
SERVICE ORIENTED. AND SO WE NEED
OFTEN WITH OUR CLIENTS AND WERE
USED TO ENGAGING WITH THEM IN
PERSON AND I THINK THAT'S THE
NATURE OF ALSO THE ARCHITECTURE
PROFESSION IS GATHERING PEOPLE
AROUND THE TABLE AND SOLVING
PROBLEMS TOGETHER. WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DO THAT SUCCESSFULLY VIA
TELEWORK BUT I THINK THAT- THERE
IS A LITTLE BIT SOMETIMES OF THE
NEW PATIENTS WITH TECHNOLOGY- IT
MAKES IT A LITTLE MORE DIFFICULT
AS WELL I THINK TO COMMUNICATE
VIA TELEPHONE ONE WORLD WAR
LYING ON OUR COMPUTERS TO DO
THAT COMMUNICATION. BUT WE HAVE-
YOU KNOW TROUBLESHOOTING THOSE
ISSUES AS WE MOVE ALONG IN IN
THE PANDEMIC AND NOW WE HAVE A
BETTER SYSTEM FOR COMMUNICATION
FOR COMMUNICATING ON PHONES BUT
I STILL THINK THAT IT'S THE
NATURE OF ALL OF US TO REALLY
GATHER AROUND A TABLE AND SOLVE
PROBLEMS TOGETHER AND SO THAT'S
RIGHT THEY GOT A HYBRID
ENVIRONMENT REALLY STARTS TO
MAKE SENSE IN TRYING TO CREATE
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES TO ENGAGE.
TOGETHER WHEN WE NEED TO BUT
ALSO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE A LOT OF
OUR WORK- REMOTELY WHEN WE CAN
AND THEREFORE GET A BETTER
BALANCE AND STILL DELIVERED THAT
THAT CUSTOMER. SERVICE THAT WE
SO VALUE. WHO YOU'RE IN TEN TO.
OUT OF. FOR THE HYBRID ANY IN
PERSON MEETINGS. CERTAINLY OUR
VENDOR STAND THAT IN FACT I
THINK IT. IT KIND OF
REVERBERATES. THROUGH MANY MANY
ON AGENCIES AND ORGANIZATIONS
WHERE WE ARE. HAVING DIFFICULTY
REALLY GETTING THE BACK AND
FORTH THAT'S REQUIRED TO MOVE
GOAL FORWARD INFO. FOR THE
ISSUES SO WELL I THINK YOU FOR
THAT- CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN ON
YOUR NOMINATION AND YOU WILL
HAVE MY SUPPORT. FOR THE
CONFIRMATION VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR
SENATOR LAYER GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE FIRM AND I
KNOW IT'S- LATE IN THE HEARING
MAYBE IT WAS TO YOUR ADVANTAGE
THE LAST BECAUSE WE WON'T. BE
EXTENSIVE SO ARE I REALLY
APPRECIATED YOU. A MEETING
YESTERDAY MAYBE I'LL JUST US TWO
THINGS ABOUT- THAT CAME UP IN
OUR MEETING. ONE IS THAT. ARE
YOU HAVE NEW ASSIGNMENTS THIS IS
WHERE YOU DO SUSTAINABILITY
REVIEW OF PROJECTS THAT COME BY
YOU WOULD YOU DESCRIBE HOW YOU
DO THAT HOW THAT GOT ADDED TO.
JUST WHAT THAT MEANS. SURE THANK
YOU FOR MEETING WITH ME
YESTERDAY SENATOR LAYERED AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION- AS
THE SUSTAINABILITY REQUIREMENTS
AND CAL GREEN BECOME-
INCREASINGLY- I GUESS NECESSARY.
TO ADDRESS SUSTAINABILITY
SCHOOLS WE DO HAVE TO INSTILL A
MESSAGE OF PLAN REVIEW THAT
ACTUALLY ENSURES THAT THE LARGER
MESHES MEASURES ARE ACTUALLY
GETTING IMPLEMENTED OFTEN SOME
OF THE MEASURES AND CAL GREEN
ARE EASY TO IMPLEMENT AND HAVE
BEEN BECAUSE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE- SEE IF PAINS OR WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- THE INSULATING
MATERIALS THOSE ITEMS ARE
PROLIFIC IN. CONSTRUCTION AND SO
WE KNOW THAT OFTENTIMES THOSE
ARE THE ALTERNATIVES THAT THEY
HAVE TO INSTALL- THOSE TYPES OF
MATERIALS IN BUILDINGS AND THE
YOU KNOW THAT THEY'RE EASY TO
PROCURE EASY TO INSTALL IN THE
BUILDINGS IN FACT THERE ARE THE
PREDOMINANT SUPPLY THAT'S OUT
THERE. BUT THERE ARE OTHER ITEMS
THAT WE'VE IMPLEMENTED- LIKE
SHADE TREES AND ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING THAT ARE SITE SPECIFIC
AND THEY'RE TRIGGERED WHEN AN
ACTION IS TAKEN EITHER YOU KNOW
ON A PARKING AREA OR NEW PARKING
AREA- OR ANY SITE IMPROVEMENT OR
REHABILITATION OF LANDSCAPES AND
SO WE DO NEED TO LOOK AT THOSE
PROJECTS A LITTLE MORE
CAREFULLY. AND ENSURE THAT WHEN
IT'S NEEDED TO HAVE THE
SUSTAINABILITY FEATURES
INSTALLED THAT WERE ACTUALLY
CHECKING TO ENSURE THAT THAT
HAPPENS AND SO IT IS. A PROCESS
THAT WE TAKE IN OUR INTAKE IF
IT'S NOT INCLUDED AT INTAKE WE
DON'T DELAY THE REVIEW BUT WE DO
FLAG IT AND WE ASK THAT YOU
DESIGN PROFESSIONAL TO COME BACK
WHEN THEY COME BACK. WITH RETURN
FROM THE COMMENTS THAT THEY
PROVIDE THAT DOCUMENTATION PRIOR
TO THE FINAL REVIEW SO OUR GOAL
IS NOT TO NECESSARILY DELAY THE
SUSTAINABILITY REVIEW NOR IS IT
TO DELAY THE PROJECT IT'S TO
ENSURE THAT IT'S INCLUDED AND TO
GIVE THE DESIGN PROFESSIONAL
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPLEMENT THE
DRAWING SET IF IT HAS BEEN
OVERLOOKED. WELL WE PROCEED WITH
OUR REVIEW AND THEN CATCH IT- AT
THE. END OF DURING BACK CHECK
COM. AS THE- ELEMENTS IN CALGARY
WILL BE LOW AT EACH OF THOSE
ITEMS INCREMENTAL. THANK YOU I
REALLY THAT NINE HOW THAT ADDED
AND- IT HOW THAT'S NOT DONE AS A
MATTER OF COURSE I THINK THAT'S
A GREAT PROCESS. THE OTHER THING
I THOUGHT I WOULD ASK YOU ABOUT
IS THAT- IT IN THE COBWEBS OF
MINE MINE DIED REMEMBER THAT
FIFTEEN OR SEVENTEEN YEARS AGO
THERE WAS A HUGE BACKLOG OF
PROJECTS IN THE STATE ARCHITECT.
AND THAT. HE A YOU KNOW AS A
LEGISLATOR I GOT LOTS OF
COMPLAINTS FROM PEOPLE WHAT WAS
HOLDING UP BUSINESS. HOLDING UP
CONSTRUCTION. THE THERE ARE A
WHOLE HOST OF THINGS AND YOU
INDICATED. BOB YESTERDAY IN OUR
MEETING THAT IT'D BEEN ROUGHLY
TEN YEARS SINCE THAT BACKLOG
EXISTED AND ARMED WONDERED IF
YOU WOULD TALK ABOUT. THAT
BECAUSE THE THING I ASKED YOU
WAS HOW DO YOU MAKE SURE. YOU
NEVER START TO GET A BACKLOG
AGAIN HOW DO YOU MONITOR IT HOW
DO YOU MAKE SURE YOU'RE ASKING
FOR HELP IF THAT MATERIALIZES I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THAT'S JUST A KEY PART OF YOUR
DEPARTMENT I. WONDERED IF YOU
COMMENT ON THAT. SURE THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION- NO I PREVIOUS
THAT PREDECESSOR- HAVE SET IN
PLACE OUR ELECTRONIC PLAN REVIEW
PROCESS HOW ABOUT. I WANT TO SAY
ABOUT FOUR FIVE YEARS AGO NOW
WHERE WE ACTUALLY HAVE AN
APPOINTMENT SCHEDULING PROCESS
AND THEN AN ELECTRONIC PLAN
REVIEW PROCESS SO WE ARE
COMPLETELY SUSTAINABLE
ORGANIZATION WITHOUT REALLY ANY
PAPER. AND DOES WHAT THAT
APPOINTMENT PROCESS DID WAS IT
GAVE THE SIX WEEKS AT THOSE
DRAWINGS WOULD NORMALLY SIT AT
DSA WAITING FOR REVIEW HE GAVE
IT BACK TO THE DESIGN
PROFESSIONAL SO NOW MUCH LIKE
WHEN YOU GO TO THE PHYSICIAN AND
YOU NEED TO MAKE AN APPOINTMENT
TO SHOW UP. FOR YOUR YOU KNOW
HEALTH CHECK WE'RE DOING THE
SAME THING THE DESIGN
PROFESSIONAL HAS SIX WEEKS IN
ADVANCE TO SCHEDULE THAT
APPOINTMENT AND SCHEDULE A TIME
TO HAVE THAT- PROJECT COMMAND WE
TAKE THEM AT ALL TIMES. OF THE
DESIGN PROFESSIONAL CAN SCHEDULE
THAT SIX WEEK APPOINTMENT
ANYTIME UNLIKE YOUR DOCTOR
APPOINTMENT IT IS NOT LIKE YOU
HAVE ONLY CERTAIN TIMES WHEN YOU
CAN SUBMIT THEY JUST IT'S JUST
THAT THEY CAN SUBMIT SIX WEEKS
IN ADVANCE AND WE CAN PLAN SIX
WEEKS IN ADVANCE SO WE HAVE A
DASHBOARD. THAT WE LOOK AT OUR
STAFFING MODEL AND LOOK TO SEE
WHO IS WRAPPING UP A PROJECT AND
START WE CAN START ASSIGNING THE
PROJECT AS IT COMES IN BECAUSE
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE SIZE OF
THE PROJECT WE UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE PROJECT IS AND WE KNOW WHEN
IT'S GOING TO BE SUBMIT. AND
THAT WAY WE CAN- KEEP TRACK OF
OUR- ARE PLAN REVIEW PROCESS ON
OUR DASHBOARDS EACH SUPERVISOR
HAS A DASHBOARD BUT WE ALSO HAVE
A METRICS- DEPARTMENT WHO
ESTABLISHES REPORTS EVERY DAY
EVERY DAY WE GET THAT AS
TO THE SUBMITTALS THAT ARE
COMING IN. AND WHEN WE HAVE THAT
SIX WEEK LOOK AHEAD WERE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT SOME OF OUR
OTHER TOOLS IN ORDER TO ENSURE
TIMELY PLAN REVIEW- IF OUR STAFF
IS FULLY OCCUPIED WITH THE
PROJECTS THAT COME IN AND THOSE
ARE CONSTRUCTION I'M SORRY
CONSULTING CONTRACTING AND ALSO
OVER TIME. AND WHILE WE LIKE TO
RESORT TO THOSE- LAST WEEK DO
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE STAFF IS BUSY AND WE
TAKE PRIDE IN IN DOING THE WORK
THAT AS WELL AS YOU DO- THEY ARE
THEY DO GIVE US A OPPORTUNITY
THAT. WE NEED TO WE CAN. REACH
OUT TO WORK IN. AND SAY HERE
GIVE US YOU KNOW- A TASK ORDER
TO DEFINE YOU KNOW WHAT THIS
ROLE IS. HOW MUCH IT'S GONNA
COST AND SO WHEN THAT PROJECT
CONSENT WE CAN ASSIGN IT TO THEM
IF WE ARE AT CAPACITY. SO WE DO
HAVE METHODS TO ADDRESS OUR
WORKLOAD AND WE TAKE PRIDE THAT
WOMEN ARE PROJECTS COMES IN WE
USUALLY GET TO IT WITHIN FIVE
DAYS OF THAT SUBMITTED. SOME
MIDDLE DATE. AND PROCESS THAT
THROUGH THROUGH THAT REVIEW AND
AS I PREVIOUSLY STATED IF THERE
ARE SOME POP ELEMENTS OF IT THAT
ARE. MISSING WE INFORM THE
CLIENT AND GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY EITHER TO IF IT'S
CRITICAL FOR THE INITIAL REVIEW.
TO PROVIDE IT TO US WITHIN. A
TWENTY FOUR TO FORTY EIGHT HOUR
PERIOD OR IF IT'S SOMETHING LIKE
A SUSTAINABILITY REVIEW THAT'S A
SUPPLEMENTAL DOCUMENT. GIVE THEM
TIME TO WHILE IT'S IN REVIEW
SUPPLEMENT THE DRAWINGS. SO THAT
WE CAN KEEP PROJECTS MOVING
FORWARD. THANK YOU FOR THAT. A
DETAILED ANSWER AND I THINK THE
THING FOR US IS TO SIT. OF RE
INTERESTINGLY CONFIRMATIONS ARE
ALSO THE CHANCE TO DO OVERSIGHT.
AND SO. OUR THIS IS OUR WAY OF
CHECKING INTO BACKLOGS WERE THE
YOU HAVE LONG WHETHER YOU KNOW
WHAT TO DO. I WOULD JUST SAY.
THAT IF THERE'S EVER A TIME WHEN
RESOURCES ARE SUCH THAT BACKLOG
START TO ACCUMULATE TO HELP YOU
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO DO
WHAT IT TAKES TO. TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU CAN DEAL WITH MARK
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR RESPONSES I
APPRECIATE. THANK YOU SENATOR.
SENT GROWTH. THANK YOU MADAM FOR
TEN GOOD AFTERNOON MISS CLAIRE
HOW HOW ARE YOU I THANK YOU GOOD
AND I JUST HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS-
JUST TO I PROBABLY WON'T TAKE AS
LONG AS THEM THAT MY COLLEAGUE
OF FORMER SECRETARY DID. M. BUT
I DO. OKAY HE HAS ME ON A
STOPWATCH SO I JUST I NOTICED IN
YOUR WRITTEN RESPONSES TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE- YOU SAID THAT
YOU HAVE SOME- BUILDING
STANDARDS IN ADMINISTRATION
THREE XIN ADMINISTRATIVE RELATED
REGULATIONS. THAT ARE ADVERSELY
AFFECTING THE CERTIFICATION OF
THE BOARD CONSTRUCTION OF
MODERNIZATION I JUST NOTICED
THAT. A COULD YOU ELABORATE ON
THAT OR COULD YOU SHARE YOUR
SPECIFIC CONCERNS. ABSOLUTELY SO
THERE IS A REGULATION THAT HAS
BEEN IN PLACE IN THE CALIFORNIA
MINISTRY OF CODE THAT STATES
THAT NGUYEN- THE SCHOOLS
PERFORMING MODERNIZATION. AND
THAT MODERNIZATION ARRIVES AT
50% OF ITS VALUE OF THE BUILDING
VALUE- THEN IT TRIGGERS A FULL.
UPGRADE FOR THE STRUCTURAL
SAFETY ELEMENTS OF THE PROJECT.
AND SO FOR A LOT OF THESE
HISTORICAL BUILDINGS- IT'S NOT
YOU KNOW IT DEPENDS ON THE
BUILDING BUT THIS COULD BE A
VERY SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT
THAT WAS A PLAN FOR BY OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. AND SO WHERE
WE USED TO SEE THIS HAPPEN-
PERHAPS MAYBE ONCE A YEAR WE ARE
NOW SEEING APPROXIMATELY TEN
PROJECTS A MONTH WHERE THIS IS
OCCURRING. IN VARIOUS AREAS OF
THE STATE AND SO. WHAT THAT
TENDS TO DO OBVIOUSLY DERAIL
YEARS OF PLANNING THAT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE PERFORMED
AND A LOT OF THIS REASON IS
BECAUSE THE- COST OF
CONSTRUCTION FLUCTUATE SO
GREATLY AND SO IF THEY'RE
PLANNING VERY CLOSE TO THAT 50%
MARK. THEN THE COST OF
CONSTRUCTION WHEN THEY'RE
PROVIDING THAT COST ESTIMATE
COULD REALLY SEND IT OVER THE
MARK AND THEN CREATE ALL THIS
ADDITIONAL WORK. YEAH SO- WE
DIDN'T WANT TO- WE NEED TO WE
REALIZE WE NEED TO LOOK AT THIS
REGULATION THAT'S BEEN ON THE
BOOKS FOR A WHILE AND SEE HOW WE
CAN EITHER ADJUSTED FOR
IMPROVEMENT SO THAT WE CAN HAVE.
THE STRUCTURAL SAFETY WE NEED
BUT ALSO ADDRESS RESILIENCY AND
SUSTAINABILITY IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR DSA TO SAY THAT
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO BE
SUSTAINABLE ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS TO
BE SUSTAINABLE AND THEN WE HAVE
A REGULATION THAT MAY ENCOURAGE
SCHOOLS TO ACTUALLY DEMOLISHED
BUILDING IN ORDER TO PROCEED.
BECAUSE IT MAKES MORE SENSE TO
BUILD A NEW ONE- OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S NOT VERY- IT DOESN'T BODE
WELL FOR THE ENVIRONMENT IT'S A
VERY CARBON INTENSIVE. YEAH SO
WE HAVE ARRANGED A TASK FORCE
THAT ACTUALLY OUR FIRST MEETING
WILL BE MARCH NIGHT- WE'VE
ENGAGED WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITH ARCHITECTS WITH-
STRUCTURAL ENGINEERS AND OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS AS
WELL. AND WE'RE GETTING TOGETHER
AND TRYING TO EXPLORE AND
UNDERSTAND WHERE THE PROCESS CAN
WE HAVE HE TRIGGER POINTS THAT
MAYBE WE DO. THAT THAT THE
PROJECTS NOT SO VOLATILE
DEPENDING ON THE CONSTRUCTION
COSTS RIGHT OR- JUST YOU KNOW
THE REGULATION ITSELF THAT SAYS
LET'S PRIORITIZE SAFETY BUT IT'S
LOST A LOOK AT SUSTAINABILITY
RESILIENCY AND HOW CAN WE WRITER
REGULATIONS SO THAT. OUR SCHOOLS
CAN BETTER PLAN BUT THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT THE STUDENTS ARE
SAFE WHEN THESE FACILITIES ARE
MODERNIZE. SO I'M VERY HOPEFUL
OF THIS PROCESS WE USE TASK
FORCES BEFORE- I'VE IMPLEMENTED
TWO OR THREE OF MY TIME AT TSA.
THEY'VE BEEN EXTREMELY
SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
AN EXPLORATION OF THE PROJECT
TOGETHER AND THE PROBLEM
TOGETHER AND LISTENING TO EACH
OTHER AND UNDERSTANDING YOU KNOW
WHERE WE WHERE WE ALL NEED TO
WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT
WERE MEETING THAT GOAL WHICH IS
TO TRY TO SAVE SOME OF OUR
EXISTING FACILITIES. TRY TO MAKE
THEM STRUCTURALLY SAFER TRY TO
MAKE THEM MORE SUSTAINABLE AND
TRY TO DELIVER THESE PROJECTS ON
TIME FOR THE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I DON'T NEED
TO ASK MY SECOND QUESTION
BECAUSE IT WAS- HAVE YOU ENGAGED
IN A PROCESS TO ADDRESS THIS
REGULATORY PROBLEM THAT SEEMS TO
BE. PROHIBITING SCHOOLS FROM
BEING ABLE TO DO A MODERNIZATION
WITHOUT TEARING DOWN COMPLETE
BUILDINGS. AND YOU HAVE AND YOU
GAVE A VERY GOOD EXPLANATION FOR
IT SO I AM FINISHED I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR CONFIRMATION.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ANSWERING MY QUESTION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR GROWTH
SENATOR COME LONGER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM AYE- JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION- ARM AN APOLOGIES IF
MAYBE YOU TO ADDRESS THIS
EARLIER AND JUST- AS IT RELATES
TO THE CAL GREENE RULEMAKING
PROCESS THESE- HAVE YOU CONVEYED
YOUR FRUSTRATION AT THE SLOW
NESS OF IT. WELL THE PROCESS
ITSELF IS STEPS THAT STATUTE AND
I THINK IT'S NOT THAT IT'S- A
SLOW PROCESS SO MUCH IS THAT THE
LENGTH OF THE ROCESS- TENDS TO.
FLUCTUATE THE ENGAGEMENT- BUT
THE PROCESS IS NECESSARY IN
ORDER FOR US TO DO OUR OUTREACH
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO IMPROVE REGULATIONS ON AN
EIGHTEEN MONTH CYCLE. AND SIX
MONTHS OF THAT TIME IS REALLY
WORKING WITH OUR CONSTITUENTS
WHETHER WHICH WOULD BE THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS. AND
ENGAGING WITH THEM AND LETTING
THEM KNOW WHAT THE PROPOSED
REGULATIONS ARE WHY WE'RE DOING
IT WE ALSO HAVE TO DO COST
ANALYSES SO THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK THAT GOES INTO DEVELOPMENT
OF THE REGULATIONS BUT THERE'S
ALSO A LOT OF PACKAGE PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT AND PUBLIC
INVOLVEMENT. AND IT ONCE IT ONCE
WE DO OUR INITIAL PRE CYCLE OUT
REACH- AND WE ESTABLISH WHAT THE
REGULATIONS ARE AND THEN THERE
IS A WHOLE NOTHER FORMAL PROCESS
THAT GOES THROUGH BUILDING
STANDARDS AND THERE'S OTHER
CHECKPOINTS TO ENGAGE. AND IT'S
TRYING TO DRAW THEM BACK INTO
THOSE CHECKPOINTS TO ENGAGE
BECAUSE AS WE RECEIVE COMMENTS
WE DO HAVE THE ABILITY TO ADJUST
THE REGULATION- SOMEWHAT. AND SO
IT'S REALLY TRYING TO REACH OUT
TO THE SCHOOLS AND SAY HERE'S
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU TO
COMMENT HERE'S ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU TO
PARTICIPATE. COME JOIN US COMING
FORM AND IT'S- DEPENDING ON
BECAUSE IT'S EVERY EIGHTEEN
MONTHS DEPENDING ON HOW BUSY ARE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE ESPECIALLY
RECENTLY WITH THE PANDEMIC BUT
ALSO AT THE START OF SCHOOL OR
YOU KNOW IF IT'S IN THE MIDDLE
OF SUMMER AND THAT'S WHEN THAT
TIME FALLS AND THEY'RE VERY BUSY
WITH CONSTRUCTION ON THEIR
CAMPUSES. SOMETIMES IT'S HARDER
TO GET THEIR ATTENTION SO WHILE. THE PROCESS IS- YOU KNOW
SECONDS. PRETTY MUCH A STATUTE
AND THERE'S A REALLY GOOD REASON
FOR IT IT'S REALLY US TRYING TO.
ELICIT THEIR ENGAGEMENT TO KEEP
THEM INTERESTED SO THAT THEY'RE
AWARE OF WHAT'S COMING IN THE
FUTURE. GOT IT THANK YOU AG IS
SOMEONE WHO HAS SPENT SOME TIME
IN THE LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT- I. AM ALWAYS
INTERESTED IN WAYS. THAT WE CAN
SORT OF ENERGIZED OUR PROCESS
EASIER SORT OF ACTIVATE THEM IN
A WAY THAT- KEEP THINGS CURRENT
BECAUSE- DISTRICTS ARE. TRYING
TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF THEIR
FACULTY AND THEIR STUDENTS AND
THE COMMUNITY THEY'RE TRYING TO
BUILD. IN A WAY THAT IS-
SUITABLE FOR THE KIND OF-
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE HAPPENING ON
CAMPUSES. BUT THEN YOU'RE ALSO
DEALING WITH COSTS AND OTHER
KINDS OF CONSTRAINTS AND TIME
CAN IMPACT ALL OF THOSE THINGS.
AND THEN IT ENDS UP YOU HAVE
SOMETHING THAT'S BUILT. IN
YOU'RE BEHIND THE EIGHT BALL
AGAIN AND SO- YOU KNOW ALWAYS
INTERESTED IN WAYS THAT WE CAN
SORT OF STREAMLINED AND ACTIVATE
THESE PROCESSES FOR FULL
ENGAGEMENT BUT- THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR. YOUR RESPONSE I HAVE
NOTHING ELSE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR CALM WATER THIS IS
BEEN A REALLY INFORMATIVE-
CONVERSATION SO I DON'T REALLY
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OTHER THAN TO
SAY HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE. THE
ROLE THAT YOU PLAY AND HOW THE-
OBVIOUSLY DIFFICULT IT IT MUST
HAVE BEEN- HAS BEEN AND
CONTINUES TO BE DURING THE
PANDEMIC. SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
SERVICE AND CERTAINLY YOUR
HISTORY AND YOUR WORK ON HOUSING
I JUST WANT TO TOSS THAT OUT
THERE- WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND NOT GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. EYE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT BUT I STILL
DON'T SEE- AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WOULD HAVE JOINED US
PHYSICALLY. SO I'M GONNA GO BACK
TO OUR INCREDIBLE AT AND T.
MODERATOR WHOSE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH US ALL DAY. AND REMIND
PEOPLE WHO WISH TO SPEAK THAT
YOUR NAME YOUR- ORGANIZATION OF
ANY AND YOUR POSITION- BRIEFLY.
AND GO TO YOU MADAM MODERATOR.
THE GENTLEMAN ONCE AGAIN MISTER
ALRIGHT ONE ZERO. WE CHANGED THE
PERSONNEL TEMPORARILY WELL AS
WELL ONE ZERO ON YOUR PHONE'S
KEYPAD. FOR IT WILL GATHER YOUR
IT WILL GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
LISTEN TO YOUR LINE NUMBER TO BE
CALLED IN WHEN CALLED ON STATE
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION FOR
THE LEGISLATIVE RECORD. AND
WE'LL GO NEXT NOW TO ALIGN
NUMBER. THIRTY FOUR NINE THIRTY
FOR YOUR OPEN. YOUR ORDER FROM
THE BECAUSE IT NOT BUT OKAY I'M
I'M THE NUMBER. GO RIGHT AHEAD
AND CALL THE NEXT WITNESS MISTER
MODERATOR. SIX ONE NINE THIRTY
FIVE LINE THIRTY FIVE LINES OPEN
GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM PRO KEVIN MEMBERS MADELINE
COOPER FROM NELSON MARC MURR ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
OF ENGINEERING COMPANIES
CALIFORNIA WE ARE PLEASED TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
CONFIRMATION OF MISS CLAIRE TO
SERVE AS THE ARCHITECT. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HER IN
THIS CAPACITY THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND THANK
YOU FOR HANGING IN THROUGH THIS-
LONGER HEARING MYSTERON RAIDER
GO RIGHT AHEAD NEXT WITNESS. MAX
IS FINE SIXTEEN SIXTEEN YEAR
OPEN PLEASE GOING TO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARC CHRISTIAN WITH
THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
ARCHITECTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF THE APPOINTMENT OF FINDING
CLARA STATE ARCHITECT IT'S
CLEAR IS VERY WELL QUALIFIED FOR
THIS POSITION SHE HAS BEEN A
LICENSED ARCHITECT FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS. SHE HAS BEEN WITH
THE DIVISION OF THE STATE
ARCHITECT FOR FIVE YEARS TWO OF
THOSE AS ACTING STATE ARCHITECT.
SHE MAY BE THE FIRST STATE
ARCHITECT APPOINTED FROM WITHIN
THE ORGANIZATION. SHE IS A
CERTIFIED ACCESS SPECIALIST
WHICH MEANS SHE'S AN EXPERT ON
ACCESSIBILITY LAWS AND
REGULATIONS. GIVEN THE ROLE OF
THE STATE ARCHITECT PASS AND
DEVELOPING THE VERY IMPORTANT
EXCESSIVE ACCESSIBILITY
STANDARDS. CERTIFICATION
SCHUERHOLZ'S QUITE MEANINGFUL
SHE HAS DEMONSTRATED HER
LEADERSHIP DURING HER TIME AS
ACTING STATE ARCHITECT. HOLDING
ELECTED LEADERSHIP POSITIONS
WITHIN THE AIA ENERGY CO FOUNDER
OF THE CERTIFIED ACCESS
SPECIALIST INSTITUTE THE
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATION FOR
CERTIFIED ACCESS SPECIALIST. SHE
HAS PROVEN HERSELF TO HAVE AN
OPEN DOOR POLICY WITH THE MANY
STAKEHOLDERS WHO LAW WORK WITH
THE POSITION OF THE STATE
ARCHITECT. WHETHER THAT IS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS STRUCTURAL
ENGINEERS THE DISABLED COMMUNITY
OR ARCHITECTS TO DEMONSTRATED
HER DESIRE TO WORK OPENLY AND
COLLABORATIVELY SO THAT TSA
PERFORMS A CONSISTENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY. I JUST SPOKE IN ON
SOME OF HER PAST AND CURRENT
ACCOMPLISHMENT. IT MAY CLOSE. ON
THE POINT OF A WHAT HERBAL CAN
ON THE APPOINTMENT OF I DECLARE
A AYE AS THE FOR. FEMALE ST RK
CAN HELP INSPIRE FUTURE
GENERATIONS OF GIRLS AND WOMEN
TO ENTER THE ARCHITECTURAL
PROFESSION BRINGING GREATER
DIVERSITY TO ARCHITECTURE THAT
INSURED MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT HER APPOINTMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS. I'M
SURE WE CURRENTLY HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENT ENGINE CAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL BE
BACK WITH YOU IN JUST A MOMENT.
I HAVING HEARD FROM THOSE IN
SUPPORT WE WILL DO THE SAME
PROCESS FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION-
I. SEE THAT THERE IS STILL NO
ONE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE PHYSICALLY SO- MISTER
MODERATOR I'M GONNA COME BACK TO
YOU- TO ALLOW PEOPLE WHO WISH TO
BE IN THE QUEUE AND SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS APPOINTMENT.
THANK YOU MEANT A LOT OF MODERN
CHURCH HERE TO A COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER. I NEVER TO BE
CALLED ME OPEN YOUR MIND BECAUSE
ZERO TO. POPULAR. I'M SURE WITH
THAT PROMPT WE HAVE NO ONE TO
DEATH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US TODAY-
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR HELP AND
ASSISTANCE- I'M GONNA HAVING
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
I'M GOING TO BRING IT BACK INTO
OUR HEARING ROOM AND CALL FOR A
MOTION. THANK YOU A SENATOR
GROWTH WHO MADE THE MOTION MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. GROVE ROVE I KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER I LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES HI THE I CAN I CAN FIVE
FIVE ZERO THIS IS UNANIMOUS AND
WE CONGRATULATE YOU WE WILL MOVE
DISAPPOINTMENT ONTO THE SENATE
FLOOR FOR CONFIRMATION AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE YOUR
TIME AND YOUR DELIGHTFUL
CONVERSATION TODAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU BEST OF LUCK
THANK YOU. I'M OKAY- THIS
CONCLUDES TODAY'S- PROBABLY
COMES OKAY I'VE GOT- YOU'RE
RIGHT I'VE GOT TO OPEN THE ROLE
ON ITEM ONE A. NATALIE SOLUTIO
I. SECRETARY OF LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
CALL THE ROLL KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER I. FIVE TWO ZERO I THAT
MOVES ONTO THE SENATE FLOOR I
ITEM ONE B. ON A LOSS SO
DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES MADAM SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL. KAMLAGER I AMAKER AYE
FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO THAT
INCLUDES EVERYTHING RIGHT MADAM
SECRETARY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DILIGENCE AND YOUR SUPPORT OF.
LET ME ALS THANK OUR COURT
REPORTERS WHO THIS IS BEEN A
LONGER HEARING THAN WE TYPICALLY
HAVE- IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF
APPOINTEES AND- SHE IS ALWAYS
INCREDIBLE TO US AND WE ARE SO
SORRY YOU'RE NOT WITH US IN
PERSON BUT WE LOVE SEEING YOU ON
THE SCREEN AND WE THANK YOU-
MAKE SURE YOU GET THOSE IN THE-
COURT MINUTES OKAY. OKAY SO THIS
CONCLUDES TODAY'S- PUBLIC
PORTION OF THE AGENDA I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN OUR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU WEREN'T
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE FOR
INSTRUCTIONS. YOUR COMMENTS AND
YOUR SUGGESTIONS ARE WE'RE TRULY
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN OUR
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD. SO
THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND CONTINUED COOPERATION ARE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES WILL
NOW MOVE TO EXECUTIVE SESSION.